this is Jocko podcast number 212 with me
Jocko willing the path of jiu-jitsu is
hard it is a hard path you have ups and
downs and there are times when you've
got to work and there are times when you
get injured and there are times when you
get mentally defeated and you feel like
you don't want to do it anymore and
those days go on and on and on but if
you do the right thing and you stay on
the path over time you will move forward
on that path you will move forward on
that path if you keep your nose to the
grindstone you move forward on that path
if you have the humility to say you know
what I still have more to learn and
that's the same way it works with life
you're going to have ups and downs in
life things are gonna go wrong you're
gonna lose businesses you're gonna lose
jobs you're gonna break up things are
going to go wrong and what you need to
do is to keep moving forward no matter
what happens keep moving forward and
jiu-jitsu is representative of life if
you stay humble and you stay on that
path you will end up achieving your goal
that will happen and it did happen
it happened to my friend here echo
Charles and those are the words that I
said in August when he received the
black belt the black belt he always
refer to the black belt is if there's
only one in the world the black belt he
received the black belt in jujitsu and
it was not an easy path and there was
much learned along the way not just
about jiu-jitsu but about life and so I
told echo at that time at some point we
would discuss that journey on the
podcast so here we are
good evening echo good evening so we did
I did immediately say well PI not
immediately but a few hours after you
got your black belt and there was a lot
we were a lot of people talking you know
we're at origin camp we were all talking
about everyone getting their black belts
you get your black belt what it's like
to get your black belt all the things
that you had been through and I said you
know what we just got a just will do we
need to do a podcast about this because
it's a journey
I know it's interesting too I was
thinking about this our last guest Joel
Struthers when he came in and before we
started recording he was he was very
humbled to be here you know he's act man
he said kay I kind of feel I you know
you here we are we're having these guys
that were from SOG that were in Vietnam
Medal of Honor recipients I mean just
really just esteemed guests on the
podcast and Joel is kind of like you
know he's a humble guy and what I what I
realize is I said well you know I'm
thinking to myself I'm still gonna learn
from you you know looking at Joel I mean
he did some really cool stuff had a good
six years in the French Foreign Legion
learn some cool lessons I want to learn
those lessons too so when I talked to
you like I want to learn what you
learned
I want to learn from you and that's part
of what makes makes me to try and get
better that's what makes me get better
is I'm I'm gonna learn from everyone you
know you know you hear someone say you
even learned something from a white belt
yeah you know that's like a saying it's
actually true you hear your seal said oh
you can still start learn something from
a new guy it's not just to say it's true
yeah so with that also some people have
asked you know over the years like how
did you and I meet so I think that's
probably a a good place to start because
we did meet from jujitsu so how do we
meet go well in jujitsu actually I
remember it probably earlier than you do
but you know but when you say like how
you can learn something from from anyone
right like how this I think I mean you
learning something from me or whatever
and I'll see it in your face every once
in a while wanna when I'll say something
it's almost like you're kind of
computing and calculating like my
interpretation of a certain like event
or incident versus your interpretation
of it so it's kind of like oh it's
almost like something's clicking in your
eye like think okay so that's what you
saw during this you know like so you can
almost kind of kind of formulate how you
come off a little bit more accurately
you know yeah how you impress on to like
the world is absolutely getting feedback
from someone on how they interpret what
you're saying is absolutely yeah because
you could be like oh yeah like I'm I
said that's so well you know like I was
so clear I was so like it even sounded
dope the way I said it you know and then
they're like you're you you know you
sounded kind of arrogant when you said
that's more a little miss yeah yeah shot
the target under shot the target if you
don't communicate with the target you
don't know yes yeah so alright so yeah
so we met um when I first met you was I
was a white belt at the boxing club he
was like I remember this zero yeah I
remember meeting you know I'm literally
thinking of like the look in your
I thinking like you will not remember
this at all but I knew of you I seen you
before over at over at a remember kids
so Dean Lister opened a little spot it
was half of a marshal of a karate gym so
he kinda I don't know that was a nice
Lake yes yeah and he had half of it he
put this big curtain it separates the
karate class in our class so I was I
went down there that's where I joined
and I saw you there and I had heard
about you from like Dean and some
interviews that he did or whatever and
then um then that's when I seen you but
I didn't talk to you or nothing like
that and it was literally like a weekend
or something and then you know how we
would go there to the boxing club which
is a different chance more of a gym a
boxing gym with jiu-jitsu and him and me
so we'd go from there to the boxing club
there and you know we'd kind of be
training at both yeah you are I only
trained at the place in East Lake like
probably ten times because it was a far
away yeah you know by far away I mean
like 35 minutes or something like that
which is pretty far well yeah when
they're - yeah the Boxing Club was
pretty close yeah victory is the closest
yes sir but nonetheless when I first
wrote with he was at the boxing club
when we were done with the to the south
of the LaVista place Reese Lake place
and then yes so I rolled with you and
you you know I don't white belt at this
time and yeah you can you know beat me
up whatever and then I remember you did
this move that you still you'll still
try to do this move to me interesting it
I don't remember it working anytime
recently but it's a uni down in sight
mouth side control and then you
basically do a forearm across the net
okay and a scenario and if your head is
facing a certain way it's really hard to
get out of this you're right so you did
that to me I think one maybe two times
this is a real surprise move because no
one thinks that they can get choked
there but you actually can't get choked
there you can tap out I tap out people
with that move yes yeah and me as a
white belt I didn't know or I didn't
have that preconceived notion that you
can't get tapped I didn't even have that
I was brand new and so you did it and I
was like oh cool uh and now in that at
that point I was like
I was one of the these guys who and asks
a lot of questions like a lot of
questions like anything I saw for the
first time like hey how'd you do how'd
you do so I asked you but you still kind
of like this where like when you meet
someone like you don't you don't how
should I say exchange pleasantries that
much yeah that's true I you know I
actually am more conscious of but now
when I meet people like let's say if I
meet someone that's sort of like listen
to the podcast obviously like I'm cool
to him because there's some kind of
connection yeah but for sure never in my
life have I been a person where I meet
someone and I'm you know having some big
open conversation with unless they're
not really it's weird because because
you know kind of what I do for a living
now is basically talk mm-hmm and and I
not a big talker mm-hmm
in if I don't know people yeah I don't
know people when I go to a party like I
would go to like let's say some kind of
a whatever party with my wife and just
not talk to it right no no look I'm not
like standing a corner brooding at
people in a jerk but I'm not gonna make
a big connection with a lot of people
right now fun someone's got cauliflower
here you might open up a little yeah
yeah yeah yeah fully like you're not the
guy who's you know in the corner telling
all the story not looking like friends
whatever yeah and and back then you were
like that as well so even like even like
when you make small talk nowadays if you
if you kind of see someone and you're
like hey you're whatever even your small
talk is like and I'm comparing this to
knowing you know for however long you
can - there's a huge disconnect like a
huge and I don't mean it in a bad way
it's just more like you're you're doing
it kind of in this almost like in an
official way you know where it's like
you're not opening kind of thing and
maybe even talking about it makes it
seem like a bigger deal than it is but
it's their big time so back then oh it
was their huge time so you're like over
there you're like yeah like this is
blank look like good you know whatever
strong what you know giving
doing the same there correct stuff
that's cool but like a like a shark
would slack ah yes that's exactly how I
feel yeah yeah
and that's what I heard too so that was
like in and I kinda just admit Sarge you
know at that point and he was sort of
the same way but it was you're you're
kind of different level in that regard
and so I was like hey how do you what
would you do there whatever and you were
like well it's like it's just what you
saw you know side mount boom put your
arm right there and just choke you
there's no big revelation it was like
I'm like cool Bradley just all right I
and I didn't cut it I didn't get the
impression that you like disliked me or
nothing which I probably would have if
you were anybody else but I knew that
you're sort of like that so whatever
jump he's like apparently you know what
I thought he was and and that was sort
of it and and I didn't like train with
you or nothing like that
not that I remember anyway and um so
this is outspread like 2005-2006 Chuck
you know yeah I don't know if you were
gone you know overseas or whatever I
guess you were right yo I went overseas
probably after I met you because I did
in the summer of 2006 are left in like
April 4 Ramadi yeah and then when did
you come back and then I came back and
start training in Stockton again October
or November of 2006 six yeah so that
when I remember first like early memory
of actually like seeing you again after
that was like well after purple belt so
that I got from belt in 2007 and I was
like competing in stuff and then you
were there and also there kind of
training with you or whatever not not
that much but yeah compete I remember
you being at the competition yeah I
remember coaching you some yes yeah yeah
and then we'll one your coat when you
were actually coaching me like on the
like right before I got injured and
stuff like we were training a lot I was
trained
and then um it was funny because you're
like the same way and with it this
actually helped me out first I was like
[__] chocolate doesn't care about me
that much you know but this is what I
realized like pretty quick is like it's
not that you don't care about me it's
like you certain things are not a big
deal which we all think are a big deal
like to you they're just not a big deal
so like that that time one a is the same
tournament as I hurt my arm the first
time and I got go go potted remember and
here's the thing when I was it like when
I was competing before that like I'd
never learn what ever since I went
because in okay so noogie it's not my
belt back then it was not by doctor it
was like if there's a big tournament it
was a novice beginner intermediate
advanced that's how I went and then if
it's a smaller tournament there's just
beginner intermediate advanced so the
when I started competing in advanced
like that's when I was sort of training
with you and at that point like I was
doing really good I was training like a
lot a lot I never and I never lost never
lost up until that that day right in
that I hurt myself so like a few matches
before I hurt myself when he gets in his
Sean Roberts by the way so you know what
Sean Roberts is right he's like he ended
up being a famous jiu-jitsu guy you know
yeah yeah yeah Sean Roberts not sure
yeah it's got it so he I go against him
and he go go he finishes me with a go-go
Club my what-ifs there you know my
family's there everything you know they
kind of expected me to win because it's
just got and they can't tell what that
was yes go Levada to is like a I'm not
going to say it's a it's a move of
humiliation to have done to you but
there is a level of it's a highlight on
the humiliation scale it's not in the
middle you know leading three million
because there's a lot of things that
have to happen and it yeah we use it a
go go plotter right go go yeah I would
say this to evaluate a Google party if
it's done to you you are the the the
budding of a highlight yes you are like
pretty much under all circumstances you
know what's so and meanwhile Sean
Roberts is a thinner like more thin guy
so when we when we face off it's like
who's gonna get smashed and Sean are huh
men yeah and he totally got me with it
like probably textbook like there was at
no point in that match that I was like
getting home or nothing he ran through
me in in tapped me out right and then so
I'm like devastating ever lost an
advanced competition I'm like devastate
my you know my family's there or
whatever my wife's like well we weren't
married at the time but she's like all
like oh man are you like okay like
worried about how I'd handle it but
something like whatever like I wasn't
that like broken up about it but it was
something it was like Alyssa and then
you're like across the arena whatever
later and you text me goes you you got
caught with the Go Go that's gotta sting
shake it off you know like nothing like
that strangely it that made me feel so
much better when you did it like when
you said that you know because I was
like it's not a big deal man this is not
a bit you know like we're in this arena
you know it's like we're not you dude
everyone's competing and it's like you
know it's so not a big deal at the end
of the day but it feels like a huge deal
you know so like I mean while I see you
across the thing like on your phone or
their tails like ah it's good but I'm
like whatever so yeah that was kind of
like how the whole deal was I ended up
getting hurt my first bicep
yeah or whatever and so I was out for a
little bit but yeah when I came back we
train some more too but uh before you
tore your bicep because there was a time
for where we were training hard at time
that was this time period right yes yeah
like I always need a alternate training
partner for Dean cuz Dean's traveling or
Dean's hurt or whatever as always have
someone else it's some up and comer
that's hungry that doesn't mind training
hard and wants to train a lot yeah so
you know you and then Andy after Andy's
who it is right now and it was way after
oh yeah Andy's way under saying like at
that time
you were training with me like I
remember we should we'd go to other
maths we were trained I know other mats
in my gym be like oh there there over
there let's get there's more room we'll
go over here yeah I remember actually
when victory first it was called
Throwdown in 8th and we went um we it
wasn't even done yet you know everyone
knows training a were like hey let's go
downstairs like no one had ever touched
these bats before and now then we're old
or whatever and the mats are still like
weird slippery because they still had
that little you know layer of yeah and
you know whatever in it but I remember
that's when you were like you know what
a good feet I forget your exact words
but it something like this you want it
what feeling free is really really good
to have your own gym to Train that I
remember that specifically but yes yeah
that was um yeah that was when I was
competing and yeah training as much as
possible so then you hurt your arm
whatever no well at what point did you
start because at this point you were
bouncer whatever what point did you
start making videos because it was
pretty early on that you decided that
you were gonna become a video log refer
to do make maker yeah yeah so we I
stopped being a bouncer and I started
getting to web with my brother from
scratch I don't know anything so it's
you know it's kind of like multimedia
you know web development graphic design
that kind of stuff I always was sorted
into that in one way or another is
growing up since a little kid where me
and Jayde my brother were kind of
standouts in that regard like drawing
and in fact I remember one time JT was
in we're in sixth grade we did you know
how you said poster contests yeah I'm
sure they still have it it's something
I'm sure but you basically they give you
a theme and then you Colly draw and
color a big poster mmm that that's you
know that follows that theme in Jade
ended up winning it uh national like
ecozy by love so you win and then it's
like yeah I really was about drunk
driving
Mothers Against Drunk Driving though so
you know you win well this is closer
actually kind of dope it was a car for
the time this is like you know sick
literally sixth-grade a car crashing
into a big can of beer that was it cool
but the way he did it was good in you
know we're real good at drawing too at
that time so he wins the school he went
to the island of Kauai that and then it
wins like the state you know then all
the winners of the state got into the
National which won any freaking wins it
thousand dollars yeah there's a lot of
money oh yeah a trip to like New York
and like all this stuff so it was kind
of a big deal just four giant so anyway
the point is like we do we we were
always into artistic and drawing stuff
so web design and graphic design it was
kind of like okay that was good and then
kind of through that I don't know so you
know the idea you watch a movie right or
a movies gonna come out then you watch
the trailer then you're like dang can't
wait to watch that movie then you watch
the balloon you're like okay cool good
movie but man the trailer was like way
better you know got me way more fired up
and like the movie the movie kinda was a
letdown for me so that whole idea that
whole phenomenon like I really was
interested in where like who made that
trailer where he got the movie and
chopped it up and got the cool parts and
told almost like a little alternate
story you know like and not necessarily
alternate remember what was there a
specific trailer there was a bunch of
them so one of the ones that I always
watched was Terminator Salvation and it
has I think whenever you say a movie and
then you give me this look of you're
waiting for me to give you a nod of like
oh yeah giving you a straight punch jerk
because I've seen terminator 1 and 2
yeah and I don't know what comes after
that but apparently salvation is no no
yeah yeah one of them turn me one which
okay so term anyone to Rio to or the
best by far
like pretty much factually the best
pretty much it's not a it's not very
much up for debate but that's back in
the day before trailers really kind of
hit their stride as far as movie
trailers go so and there's Terminator 3
which is complete
flop by the way site No so anyway Turman
airforce terminus salvation Christian
Bale isn't knowing anyway
the trailer was like really well done in
my opinion mmm and ahead I forget the
group I'm just drawing a blank but I
think it might have been like nine inch
nails or something like that where they
did they have the song called the day
the whole world went away you don't need
to sing it for us bro we'll take word
for it anyway the view that song in the
trailer and then the the way they did I
was like man this I this is like I want
to live my life like this trailer feels
or whatever as far as like you know the
videos I wanted me so there was that
there was like Clash of the Titans that
was a good one I thought yeah there's a
bunch okay so then you decided you're
gonna start making trailers what was the
first you know with you that you got
paid to make then I got paid to make yes
was with you Beth and what was it is the
film was it thrown out or we victory
nope not even that was before that well
was it so the first video I made ever
was like on a cruise like you know now
you can see him anywhere like you you
know you basically take your Academy do
this chop it up put it with music but
the first video that I made for money
was with you for like some bones yeah
yeah I made like a thing about the laws
of combat you filmed me i sat there and
talked about it you know and then they
Institute it inside their organization
yeah 18 months or so yeah yeah yeah
that's the one that the sound was off
that's funny obviously geez so and so
just let me fill in the listeners please
this is like a probably a one hour video
maybe maybe I don't know 45 minute video
yeah yeah yeah it's a 45-minute video
I'm talking I'm explaining the laws of
combat I'm talking about extreme
ownership I'm going through these things
to this screen and the the audio is off
by a half a second so it looks like a
weird old Chinese martial arts film with
the voice dub over and so I say to echo
you know I'm like hey it seems like you
know it seems like my voice doesn't
match my mouth
I'm saying it sort of has a question but
like term the first two terminators
being the factually this is a factual
situation it was no debating I was
watching my lips move with no words
coming out and I'm like this is not good
and you you pushed back on me yeah
that's what's really funny yeah as that
actually made me suspect of your whole
existence so your whole cuz you were
like you were trying to explain to me
that that was somehow like your first of
all you tell me like no no not really I
might watch though the lips move see how
there's no words coming out wait was
that the time late where you came over
and we were watching it or were you
texting me I think have you came I
started off texting you like hey can you
sink these things and your responses
were like well it's not it's not really
that often I'm like what are you talking
about and so they I probably came to
your house with a pistol and was like
okay we're gonna fix this but but you
had a serious there was a problem so
this is this this is what how and how
did you think that was okay this is this
is ok so there's three little elements
to this whole equation that'll make it
make sense okay so okay so first off I
said I wasn't necessarily acting like
this and I'm not saying I was trying to
give the impression that I knew exactly
what I was doing cuz come on let's face
it this is literally my first video that
I've ever made that anyone's actually
depending on me right so I'm like
alright so yeah I sync up the audio
whatever and I don't know how to sync up
audio no idea so I think up the audio
what I thought was like synced up yeah
and so here take a half a second just
like I said I'm used the video the one
or two videos that I've ever made was
like two minutes long so editing a two
minute videos I forget click-click-click
you edit you in it but man 45 minutes of
editing your brain and just a cop you
know like so keep me off sync by a lot
in your brain will kind of connect the
dots it's weird like you ever watch it
yeah so my brain essentially connected
it and was interpreting it as Csonka
good so you're over here saying hey it's
off sync look at this and I'm like
looking at I'm looking at
and then I'm doing all these weird
mental experiments like to be like okay
let me pause it right when he said and
it's all checking out in my brain I get
it it was and that's when I was like no
you're wrong you're wrong you're wrong
so finally you were like bro I'm like
I'm coming over and we're gonna get to
the bottom of this so I'm like yeah come
whatever so you come and we're doing it
and you're like me and you're just
seeing two different things at this
point cuz my brain is all whacked at all
jammed up because I remember like weird
I was trying to mediate we were trying
to meet a deadline - that's all staying
up like super late not getting much
sleep so so you come over we're looking
at it we're seeing two different things
until this one little part where you're
like you caught our class did this yes
and then it was like oh my gosh so it's
real clear when you clap and then the
sound comes later and you were like yeah
look at that and I'm like it all that
came crashing down like that I'm
completely wrong but that was good
because I could be like okay now I'm
gonna sink the whole 45 minutes off of
this one thing you see I'm saying so
that's that's what happened there thing
about that first video - that was like
the beginning of a seal on front
essentially and that was cause when you
think okay so I revisited that video
like last year just going through what
year was that do you happen to remember
that 2010 yeah yeah so a chillon front
wasn't officially formed yet I think
that's like right after you retire yeah
yeah yeah man I looked at it's a year
ago I look I bring up the video looking
over hard drives or whatever I bring it
up on let me check this out you're all
young so funny it's like you're all
young looking man your son is saying all
ashlyn front stuff but super like early
beginnings of it I'm saying I was like
comments really interesting to watch now
that like I know like all the content or
whatever it's funny but yeah that's what
it was ilan front 1.0 yes that is and
the second video was with you as well
that was the victory the throwdown was
it victory yeah it was victory at that
time that was victory yeah you know and
which video was it the outtakes from
some of those videos are awesome
yeah those bills later on it was just
like one where do you mister is like
monkeys giraffes girl yes that cracks me
yeah but that I think that those the
victory
that's how like people started to know
around like here and around San Diego
that I did video because I did a series
of them and that just kind of were like
I just tried to make them like kind of
like movie trailer and of dramatic and
no one at that time was doing anything
like that as far as like making videos
for companies or whatever and so it you
look at them now and they're like
they're pretty cheesy now but back then
it's kind of like all day you know ya
know those were like those were really
good videos for that time period yeah
and I sort of put my name on them not
sorta I straight I put my name on them
you know when we upload them whatever
that and that's how people are like oh
you're a collage you're the one that
does those videos like that you know I
guess I mean it's kind of distinct or
whatever so that's how I kind of kind of
gained like some people started knowing
some fame no no nothing but people
started knowing I mean really recognized
oh yeah okay so now there's a chunk of
time now we're talking because we didn't
start this podcast until 2015 and these
are easy dates for me to remember
because extreme ownership came out in
October of 2015 but I was on Tim Ferriss
podcast that came out like September
25th 2015 and then I was on Rogen like
December 8th or something mmm 2015 and
then we started this two weeks later
this this podcast I remember I was like
let's get it out before Christmas
yeah and we did we got out like 22nd of
December or something like that
so there's five years between okay you
made the first echelon front 1.0 video
between that time period and 2015 what
what are you doing okay so you're making
other videos you had some but you
actually had some pretty big pretty big
videos right you did well let's just
start with the Hanaa show right yeah so
the Hanafi show yeah so you well before
like after the victory that was started
this cascade of like other people
wanting me to do that
good videos so which was perfect because
I kind of got thrown into the mix like
and had to like I had to learn yeah like
hard like that no better way to learn
than getting thrown well though there
aren't better ways but it was a way as a
way you're gonna have to learn ya hit a
sink or swim and you started swimming
crawl stroke Oh Astro rest stroke side
stroke yeah and like mistakes you make
like you really learn the lesson because
it's not like oh I made the mistake in
my freaking what was your next day after
there was the next like big break after
victory Oh
a big one I worked for a guy Blake Malan
and that was like as far as content goes
he was like okay it was kind of cool you
know corporate and stuff like that um
compared to the stuff I do now well you
would make early which is what is what I
noticed when you make wouldn't those
early videos that I was in when I watch
them I'm like this the same thing we're
doing right now almost oh yeah
like the same especially you see the
well like you said like the thing that
all the things I'm saying then it was
like oh yeah we if we would have known
then we just said okay let's just start
making more you know and really when you
think about the whole thing as a big
picture it's that's literally what
happened so like when you like when
we're making the victory videos right
there's so many outtakes like and most
of them are me and you cuz you're
messing with me the way always message
me like you're like there's this one
where you're like cuz okay and you you
you're kind of smart you like you and I
don't mean smart like you're uh
observant you're more observant than the
normal person so I'm new to video and I
figured out really early when I do
shoots with people I just press record
cuz a lot of the good stuff you can get
with people is one they don't know
you're recording right when I'm talking
to them they're doing something else
they say something they're trying to at
least loosen up and they're doing
whatever and there's a lot of good stuff
come from there right and you picked up
on that pretty quick and you're like
you're recording aren't you guys you
press them what the way you said it was
like god that's literally the same stuff
you know you know what else is funny you
got that one video of our old CrossFit
instructor yeah and he's saying he's
saying I'm gonna try and summon my inner
Chaka which is
weirdoes how did he we had even seen me
before well where'd that come from
amen everybody knew men yeah that was
random but yes uh yeah yeah yeah so I
yeah I did some some of that then yeah
I'm working with Blake because I was
it's like an ongoing thing which that's
what I really liked about like doing
video or the type of videos I like to do
is like ongoing one stuff where I could
like think of like cool little themes
for the next one you know kind of thing
so I did that for a while and then um
and then I tried to and then I want to
make like movies and stuff like I think
like anyone who does video you did you
did some martial arts some grappling
stuff too those were some pretty good
videos and you're actually traveling to
do those videos which one like metamoris
oh yeah yeah yeah some good you did some
really cool metamoris videos they were
kind of pre fight right yeah like a kind
of like a high-dose countdown type
videos 34 30 or whatever yeah kind of
like a little mini documentaries like
about the person in the fight coming up
yeah yeah and that actually doing those
a lot that's how I met a lot of the big
jujitsu players and how even more how
that spread like through the jiu-jitsu
community outside of San Diego like okay
that guy makes like videos or whatever
so I did that and at the same time I met
rasaan who is Hinata laranja I met him
and I was like brother this guy needs
like a show so we made a show with him
and we're gonna so do I think six six
altogether those are hilarious oh yeah
those are epic yeah and those are on
flex point TV well they're on YouTube
yeah but I we're on YouTube oh just just
go ahead not to learn on just show or
yeah flicks wink TV they're on there
yeah no you're right um but we had
that's a hard one too that was hard to
make given where I was in my career will
say because it's like okay I can if I
was just doing that full-time which I
kinda was at a little pocket I was just
doing that full-time you could do it but
cuz consider what you got to do is just
you know I don't have this huge
production studio with people like
arranging everything so we got to
basically arrange my schedule because I
still gotta work
stuff like I was weird me and Jayde
we're putting money into it we were
spending money to produce this show so
there's that and then there's I got to
work right I have other stuff to do so I
got a schedule with myself man we filmed
in LA it was two hours away um where'd
you bought space to juice it's called
the Dream Factory
la someplace that you were paying to use
yeah you rent out the studio yeah it's a
it's little set there this is pretty
dope though it was it was really cool um
and then so my schedule the dream
factory schedule which it wasn't too bad
cuz you know you can schedule it in
advance or whatever but not social
schedule and then the select it because
the guests are celebrity types bass
route in Frank Shamrock like Hanner like
all these so you got a schedule with
them as well like Kenny Florian was the
first one that was really fun show it
was really hard to get together and put
on yeah so when when I had a career and
then towards the end of us filming that
my career started to go up and up even
more so it's like man that I I can't do
it I just couldn't do it we couldn't do
it so yeah so it stopped but that's a
funny one yeah all everyone's will all
like watch him again and it's freaking
it's funny yeah no he's a hilarious guy
it was a it's a good show great show and
then meanwhile you and I are still
training hard I mean we're trying hard
this whole time you were one of my
primary training partners this entire
time yeah and then at like I just kind
of told part of the story but I go on
Tim Ferriss his podcast and he tells me
to start a podcast and you reminded me
of this we actually had talked about it
a little bit mm-hmm wait were you trying
to convince me to do one you know so you
told me that we should do a podcast that
you can figure it out or whatever yeah
and and then I was on Rogan and that's
why at the end of the first time I was
on Rogan show I said echo get it you
know get ready because in the middle of
Rogan show he says hey you should have a
podcast which come to find out Joe Rogan
tells everybody that everyone who should
have one
oh yeah and but I listened thankfully
and it was you know bit both hearing it
from Tim and Joe was was
was a convincing and I mean I would have
done it just off Tim but the book it was
like I was on Tim then the book came out
then I was doing that thing and just
barely got done doing kind of the the
book promotions in New York City when I
came home and that's when Rogen is so it
all happened pretty quick but yeah
having both those guys say it so then
but I do remember this conversation for
sure I came back from Rogan and I said
hey we're gonna do a podcast are you
good you know can can you make it can
you make it and you said I'll tell you
tomorrow because I remember you
specifically said I'll tell you tomorrow
you could you didn't have an answer for
me right then the next day you come in a
train I come in to train and you said
hey I know I can do the podcast I
figured it all out I know what I got to
do and then you said let me be on it too
and I said what are you gonna do and you
said I'll be normal and you be you and I
thought that was a pretty good idea and
and plus more important I didn't want to
sit and talk to myself I'd rather talk
to you and because you and I would talk
on the mat anyways and oftentimes we're
talking about subjects that we would
that were interested in so why not be
able to sit there and talk to someone
and you're super humble guy I was like
yeah I could you know we hang out all
the time so if there's one person that I
can see that can sit there and listen
and not feel like hey I gotta throw my
two cents in on everything it's like
okay cool
like let's do this so that's how we
ended up doing this yeah yeah and the in
the yeah the timeline little bit okay so
yeah and just from my perspective I
remember very clearly too by the way um
when you were on Tim for like okay so
most you listen to me on Tim Ferriss
yeah oh yeah oh yeah right when he came
out that was good even and I knew you
for a long time but that was a really
good one that was a really good great
podcast tim was think about Tim Tim I I
mean you think about the caliber of
people that Tim Ferriss has on his
podcast
and it was my buddy Kirk parsley who
introduced me to Peter attea with the
purpose like Kirk was trying to trying
to hook me up and and Peter when I
talked to Peter who I'm now you know
good friends with Peter too but you know
it was the same thing like they're
trying to dis just decipher if I would
be a person that would be interesting
right to listen to so so awesome you
know yeah like I said curtain hook me up
with Peter Peter called Tim and said you
should have this guy on your podcast and
that was the first first interview I
ever did
no that's in my life yeah sitting in Tim
Ferriss is housed in the San Francisco
Bay Area which he doesn't own anymore
because he moved to Austin Texas but
just that like I went up there on a I
flew up there that was a good call cuz
he said we can do it over a remote and I
said now come up ya know cuz I I wanted
communicating over the phone and there's
apps and there's pauses you can't see
the person so thankfully I went up there
and you know Matt let me actually stayed
the night it was just awesome man Tim's
just was super cool and then so that
podcast happens so you listen to that
one oh yeah that's interesting that you
sort of figured that that communication
thing cuz that's a huge deal like if you
can go if you have the option to go in
person or over Skype of course you can
choose in person that kind of seems
obvious but I feel like people don't
understand how much of a difference that
that makes like it's denied in there
it's a 90 day situation I was working
for the Admiral in charge of all the
seals and there was a meeting happening
in DC like at the Pentagon and the
Admiral had a small a small decision was
being made and he had an opinion on it
and someone else had another opinion on
it and he talked to the guy that was
making the decision it was like hey you
know do you want me to come out here for
this meeting and the guys like well you
don't have to and the Admiral is like
okay cool cuz it for the Admiral and I
they meant us getting on the
you know on a flight fly in six hours
not like we have a jet like we're gonna
get on a commercial flight we're gonna
stay the night and some random hotel bla
bla bla so he goes okay well you
understand my perspective boss sounds
good if you don't need me out there I
won't come so we did a VIP it was a
video teleconference and I'm sitting in
there and the decision goes the other
way mm-hmm and the Admiral goes he soon
as we got off he looked at me he said I
should have gone to that meeting yeah
and I was like Roger that boss you you
face to face is a big deal yeah
especially if there's no relationship
established yeah if you if you don't
have a relationship with someone you
need to go build it and you build it as
much as you possibly can face to face
yeah yeah and there's and there's a lot
of I mean there's a lot of over obvious
stuff you know but you know to figure
that when you figure that it's like okay
these for these obvious reasons or
whatever but not so obvious reasons are
just the little teeny tiny almost
subconscious subtleties of being there
with someone even like split seconds in
a conversation can like can make a
difference between like if it's like
cohesive or feels cohesive for sure and
that's not and that's of course from
person to person but from people
listening as well so like that that's
why I like I think that was a good good
move for you to just make that make that
sacrifice I can go up there and be there
with him ya know it was awesome and Tim
was pretty in the groove at that time
like he he knew how to do it and he and
also the format of his podcast was like
you knew kind of what I kind of knew
what he was gonna ask about and and yet
you could veer off and talk about other
subjects so it was like a really nice
way to kick things off and now that I've
done a bunch of television interviews
podcasts are just infinitely more
comfortable for me you know so some
people they don't want to get trapped in
some long term conversation and after
remember what they just said and
formulate thoughts fresh on them on the
spot on the moment whereas because the
TV people that are doing TV interviews
they they're not formulating thoughts at
that moment they go into that with a
preconceived statement they got four
sentences that they're gonna say and
that's what they're gonna say it doesn't
really matter what they get asked so
some people would prefer to do that some
people would prefer to do along I don't
mind doing either but it's infinitely
more fun yeah and thought-provoking and
intellectually stimulating to actually
have a legitimate conversation with and
with with Tim which was which was
awesome so that was a very cool way for
me to kick things off we're lucky yeah
and and me I was just like probably
millions of people who like knew about
Joe Rogan listening to Joe Rogan's
podcasts which that's kind of like the
standard you know that that top standard
of podcasts but here's the thing about
it's like since is so conversational
where he's like just talking in there in
the early days of Joe Rogan podcast he
um he would just talk to like read ban
and like his friends and they're just
talking about stuff you know um now it's
like there's a lot more to it for sure
but back then it was like oh these are
just guys cruising down in their
basement or some cool room that they're
just basically what we all sort of do it
anyway and talk [__] with with each
other and with friends and so I think me
like millions of other people were like
man that'd be so cool to be able to do
that do a podcast like that you know
just talking with my friends or whatever
and then so being in jujitsu I think
that a lot of people are in this same
boat where they know the guy who like
when he's kind of talking everyone sort
of just listens and likes to chime in
and whatever right so like with us and
Judy she was like you and even Dean when
he'd talk about jujitsu or stories or
whatever like they there's a lot of cool
conversations that go on on the mat
after were before Jia to whatever
and now those things would always go on
those are the things were going on way
before it's in Ferriss interview right
so before the whole podcast idea we
already had I think I was like a lot of
people we already had kind of for lack
of a better way of putting it like
dreams of doing some cool podcasts like
everyone had that thought not that we
were ever gonna pursue it or nothing
like that but they thought like wouldn't
that be so cool if we could have a
podcast like Joe Rogan does and have it
be like a good you know successful one a
lot of you and you get even nowadays
people young like all the time saying
like oh yeah like I want to start my own
podcast
yes right cuz it's like when you listen
to two people talking it's like man
that's your job man that's the coolest
thing in the world so I already had that
in my brain so when you went on Tim
Ferriss I was like man when he was like
you should do but yeah you should do we
should do apply it to me that was like
we should do a pod that so that's
actually beautiful Joe Rogan I was like
hey we should do a podcast in you you
were like yeah you're like we like why
would you be on like it doesn't I said
you should have me on and you were like
why like what and it wasn't like it'd be
pretty easy for me to be like dang bro
like freaking why you gotta say like
that why would you ever be on it but I
didn't think like that yeah I don't feel
like you're saying it like that
Ashton like why why would you be on it
yeah it didn't make sense to me
yeah and I had it in my brain just like
I said we're brow just be the person
you're talking to well just be normal be
a normal person you know and if I have
questions I'll ask questions like that's
not what I'm here for I'm here to just
you be talking to somebody rather than
talking through the microphone or
talking to the screen by yourself or
whatever which you know that's fine too
but it it's just in so I was essentially
like thinking of Joe Rogan's podcasts
where he's like talking to somebody the
whole time someone's there listening and
chiming in whenever that's my that was
my little engineered perceived or
conceived yeah you know you know what I
was thinking I've told you this before
when it comes to having multiple people
on the same pod like on our podcast we
don't haven't had many episodes where
we've had more than one person to
interview yeah one of the reasons is
like I already talked about and we
already talked about if there's a bunch
of people talking I won't talk yeah and
so what I was thinking myself well when
I'm getting interviewed by Tim Ferriss
he's asking me questions okay I answer
them because I'm being you know I'm
being asked a question so I'm going to
answer it Joe Rogan's asking me
questions I'm gonna answer them but if
you put me into a situation where
there's multiple people the and they
want to talk I'll just let them talk
I'll listen so in my mind I was like
thinking well if I have someone else on
there then I'll just sit there and
listen to them talk and well if people
if Tim Ferriss is telling me to have a
podcast he's not telling me to have a
podcast so I can
sit there and listen to someone else I
should be talking okay got it
so for me I had to get over the the idea
of like oh well and then I thought you
like I said earlier you're not a person
that you know when we're having a normal
conversation you're not one of these
people it took hold on waiting listen to
my viewpoint you're a person that goes
oh that's cool interesting you're all
you you will listen as much as I will
and so that's why I thought okay cool
yeah make sense good call echo Charles
yeah fully and keep in mind too yes it
was like a partially my selfish reasons
like I wanted to be on a podcast for
sure but not at any moment was I being
like hey so I can be a star too it was I
didn't have that at all like I knew what
I was getting into it I knew why I could
do it not because I have all these cool
things to say cuz I don't really like in
my mind like I'm that's not what I'm
thinking especially compared to you Tim
for that interview Tim Ferriss like bro
I literally could could never bring
anything like this to the table but if
you're over here talking about like
stuff salsa and in ice to have just
little detailed questions about that
just to clarify what you're saying or
whatever like I think that I could
facilitate in that way and not to
mention just technically I could make
the whole thing happen and I have my own
little creative ideas as well with that
so I'm figuring yeah that's it but yeah
it never even entered my mind that like
it's my podcast I'm gonna talk you know
if you're gonna sort of listen to me
sometimes so you did have a vision for
the podcast because the podcast number
one I had a vision too my vision was
basically what the podcast is right now
that's what I had the vision of hey
we're gonna execute this thing like a
military operation boom it's gonna and
the first podcast starts off with your
vision which is you know we're kind of
talking and then we kind of we kind of
drift into the beginning of the podcast
and then we kind of trip and and
actually you know as you know me and my
kind of leadership principles at this
time I wasn't a hundred percent sure
that I was right I just thought to
myself this is what it'll be and then
you had a different idea and we didn't
really talk about it until the next
podcast and I came in was like cuz I
listened to it I was like yeah that's
not we shouldn't do it that way in my
mind I was like well I don't think we
should do it that way I think this isn't
things should start
and one thing that I wanted it to do was
like start right like when you press
plates yeah
when you press I wanted people when they
put their headphones on and press play
they were like okay here it comes
and that means no intro music there's no
advertisements rolling in it's like hey
this is jockle podcast number four here
we go rock and roll and and so that's
what we started doing one podcast number
two yeah what's funny is like that um so
there's two kind of thoughts and I
didn't think it out fully but I just got
sort of felt like you know Cree it was
like a creative feeling I guess maybe
them drove that decision to make to be
like oh yeah I just sort of roll into it
casually because you know like certainly
move like movies start in all kinds of
different ways right some movies start
just the way how you were saying like
you wanted to start like it begins and
then some movies just sort of star and
fold
yeah they don't know credits no nothing
but it just sort of like people just
sort of doing something and you're like
wait what are they doing okay let me see
you know Bowman it sort of slowly
develops into this thing then it maybe
hits you with something and boo-boo-boo
so I remember like I'm vaguely remember
editing it and be like when should I
start because we're talking a bunch
before that too and then what so when
should I just roll into this and then it
was like me talking actually it was like
what was that pomegranate pomegranate
chai cuz you're drinking the white
cheese you're like white tea yeah and
then man I remember thinking that is
like yeah that was cool but then yeah
you shut it down the room like that but
you I think even thinking back on it the
way you haven't given what you took and
wound up talking about it something like
that it's yours is way better way better
yeah and I just did a bad job of out of
the gate kind of explaining yeah we
didn't talk about it but what's
interesting too is uh I think it was
Brittany Oh Brandon Peck worth yeah yeah
so he was talking to me was a while ago
he was like saying that out of the gate
with this podcast it's you know when you
hear people you go oh listen to Joe
Rogan's first podcast or listen to Tim
feel even Tim Ferriss a listen to my
first podcast I know what I was doing
it's mom
it's this it's that and it takes a while
for people to kind of figure out where
they're going I mean it might take 2030
a hundred episodes or whatever at least
30 40 50 of people trying to where they
kind of find their groove and Brandon
was like out of the gate your podcast
hasn't even changed that much I mean
it's we did make you know I mean I think
we've improved we've improved our audio
would probably speak better now but it
wasn't like it's not this drastic turn
around from we were doing something
radically different look the podcast is
essentially the same now as it was on
Episode one it's essentially the same
thing yeah
and so I've and I think that did that is
based on what I thought the podcast was
going to be like and I should have done
a better job of saying hey here's what
we're doing yeah but I didn't you know I
didn't if you remember if you and even
think about it right now you know we
don't like especially like creative
stuff like you don't we don't really
talk about you're just like you just do
it and then if I if I go off the rails
in one way or another then you'll take
me back up whatever but yeah we never
did like it was like you said like one
thing like hey we should do it in black
and white actually did you even say that
yes yes and now sorta it and then we
talked about like the enteric like the
ideal look would be like an
interrogation room I mean I use the term
interrogation room but just like super
simple whatever but yeah other than that
we're just you just sort of like let me
do whatever the varying levels of
success I guess and so then that came
out of the gate it was we got really
lucky I mean at the time there wasn't a
lot of pot there was there was a lot of
podcast but there wasn't even close to
the number of podcasts that there are
now and that went that went forward
pretty quick and next thing you know we
were like on it was it was happening
yeah I mean it was happening meaning
meaning this idea of of hey this is this
will be cool to try
they went from this will be cool to try
to like we this is what we're doing it
went to that in two or three episodes
you know I mean maybe it was even one
episode I mean first episode came out
it was like okay everyone said more and
and we did we know yeah we didn't know
we're gonna I told you were gonna do one
a week I think I think that was from the
beginning yeah it's like a we're gonna
do one a week and there's a time when I
wavered for a little while probably 40
episodes in or something I was like I
don't know if I can keep I don't know if
I can prove I don't know if I can get
this much content read I don't know if I
can do this so we might have to go to
one every two weeks and I got shut down
by the people oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
forget when that was but yes I remember
that how old I told a couple people that
s LAN Front was working with one guy
named Mike great guy I was going to a
job site with him and I just we were
driving and I said yeah you know I'm
thinking about going to like maybe put
in the podcast once every two weeks and
it was yeah it was like I told him that
you know there was a disease you know it
was like really bad and and he'd that
seen his reaction there was one other
person I told the same thing and got the
same exact reaction which was like you
they were almost he was almost like lost
for words
you know because this was early so there
was still it wasn't like you could go oh
well just listen to one that I haven't
listened to her one I haven't heard in a
while
this was hey there's only this many
episodes and I'm waiting for the next
one yeah you know I don't remember him
being up you you you know you you should
think about that and I remember what he
said he said uh he said cuz there's
people that are waiting for these to
come out yeah
and I said to myself oh yeah I gotta I
gotta get I gotta work harder yeah and I
could and I be it makes sense
yeah just for Carnegie it makes sense
too because of how like you know you
were pretty act like engaged with the
people too and out and I was too like
when people would be like hey that was
this and that's fine and you'd be
engaged like online on Twitter and stuff
like that so it kind of like it really
felt like in in a lot of ways it still
does feel like we were sorta all in this
together like everyone like me knew
doing it and then everyone whoever was
listening like they were kind of in it
too you know
so still feels like that yeah absolutely
and what's crazy is you go to Australia
where we just were and it's the same way
well
we're literally the other side of the
world and people are asking me about hey
well you said this in episode 48 did you
think I'm like yes I did think that I
could tell you know people are that into
it yeah which is awesome but back in the
day when it's when you first sort of
start your that feeling is so on the
front of your mind like it feels like we
were just all doing a people giving the
input cuz I'm trying to look I mean I
don't know about you but I was trying to
figure out a lot of stuff early on as
well like how to get certain things done
or accomplished or whatever and people
were trying to you know jumping out of
the woodwork kind of like hey you should
do this better you know you should
compress the audio you should do so I'm
taking advice I'm Lee you know so we're
all sort of in it together and there was
one episode I forget what episode it was
when it sort of hit a point where there
were so many downloads that it crashed
our website and like the podcast like
the hosting right in it um cuz you know
when you start I don't know about that I
don't know but that can stuff like where
after certain am I crazy to to think
that yeah people it seem crazy to think
that we'd have enough downloads that it
would crash the system yeah yeah so and
so of course I mean whether that whether
or not that came across my mind you know
maybe maybe not but it wasn't like a
worry I wasn't concerned about that at
all I was like no this is a it's a
computer whatever so you know you have
this host for this and the webson of
this and that and the the moment that I
was like okay there's a lot of people
like depending on this for lack of a
better way of putting it is when it
crashed on the day that I you know
released a podcast it crashes says like
you know whatever it says technically I
got to do all this stuff and just
Twitter Facebook like emails like
through the website my personal email
like coming in like where's the podcast
web and it was probably way less of a
deal then then it seemed like to me at
the time but still when you get like
essentially let's face it strangers
people I don't know like just by the
hundreds just saying where's the podcast
where's about yes it's kind of like them
saying hey where's our where's our
dinner you know like where is our pocket
and I'm like oh my gosh I'm like Rick
you know worried then at the end of like
worried about you like oh man if I'm
feeling this
and I'm not even the star the but guess
what the hell's Jocko thinking and he's
gonna kill me and all this stuff and I
regret even doing this with me should I
did it with some professional diet and
all the stuff and then every once in
while you text me hey so how's it going
so to me that the way that the way I
interpreted that how's it going is like
what the hell like the freaky but then
you call everyone's well this was a
matter of days like days are going on
still well this love this is when the
podcast
crash crash and I would text you like
hey yeah like how's it going yeah are we
making any progress yeah yeah I remember
I was on an OP I was in Iraq I was on my
first deployment and we were traveling a
far distance to the south of Iraq there
was some mayhem going on we're traveling
through this city there's eerie there's
people whistling it's just it's the
middle of the night and we get lost and
we're driving around and I'm I'm
tracking and so finally we stop and I go
up to the lead nav who's a great guy in
the lead vehicle and I look at him and I
I could see the look in his eyes like
we're lost just know where we are yeah
and I go I go
how's it going bro and and like just
that right there like he is just his
look of panic and when I said hey how's
uh how's it going bro his look of panic
went down a little bit huh
and he goes I don't know where we are
and I go okay cool that's I literally
said I go okay cool we're gonna set a
perimeter
take your time figure out where we're at
and how we can get back on track let me
know when you're ready
and he goes Roger that and and then it
allowed him to actually decompress for a
second and figure out where we weren't
it took him a minute
two minutes and then he you know we did
it so that idea of instead of texting
you whereas the smack ass people are
waiting for it yeah hey how's it going
we making any progress
yeah yes and so that became clear when
you actually would like would call and
be
you'd be like same thing I think even
said the same thing and you write many
because but I'm not used to that you
know like when something's that was
pressure you're not work yeah you're not
used to pressure well no no I'm used to
some pressure I mean let's face it I'm
from quiet not that much pressure but
okay we're you know working for people
in the deadline and hurry up and you
know like this and you know where are we
with it something going wrong and stuff
like that that okay I'm no stranger to
that but the reaction for the people who
I'm working quote-unquote for I'm not
used to them being so cool about it
usually them saying well are we you know
their frustration is now you know kind
of part of my world my added for us or
stress whatever so when you came with
that with how's it going bro it was like
I was like dang this is like it really
helped it really helped a lot so
meanwhile but still is problem still
there meanwhile I'm not getting that
level of coolness from the general
public our people and it you know it
morphed into jokes about echo how he's
not know cruising too hard and like all
this stuff which is kind of cool I guess
it's funny but anyway then our savior
Brady Lanter comes and is like hey I can
I can help you with this and all that
all knows all this technical background
stuff which I knew like a little bit
from web development but he knew like
the real tech side and then he basically
took my hand and held my hand and called
some people and boom boom you got to do
this hey we got to spend a little bit
more money to do this but we can we can
patch it up and man he got it he got it
rolling and like literally solved that
problem forever so man but point is
there where that's when I knew that yeah
like how you say like you can't really
do it twice or once every two weeks
because people were like hey we kind of
need this thing that's when it was clear
to me that yeah man it's we kind of have
like we're all kinda in this together
and you can't just boss out once every
two weeks yeah and you also can of I
mean I always feel this way about
everything too but you also can't be
like oh you know what we'll just throw
something together and put it out there
like that's not happening
yeah so it has to be a real effort 100%
of the time yeah or is it failure all
right so that's cool you get some
technical knowledge from just the
function of being the guy that's putting
this stuff together what about just from
sitting across the table for what are we
almost four years yep yeah almost four
years what are the lessons learned from
a broader perspective life wise
well they yeah it started quick too so
okay so remember get what the early
episodes like I would you're out drink
I'd have a drink going you know you say
drink you mean alcohol you're not
talking a jock would discipline go or a
jock a white tee a little hit discipline
hitter yeah I'm talking you're drinking
what did you used to drink vodka and
soda water there you go yeah or
sometimes a B or whatever but it was
like that was one of those things and
not that I was like nervous doing it but
I was like kind of nervous going into it
kind of thing and it was just yeah like
a little comfort thing or whatever and
it was one of those things where you
didn't necessarily tell me like hey you
don't need to do that you know like you
or that's week or now that you didn't
tell me that but there was always like
this feeling of it you know and it could
hit me where that's like yes pee right
yeah what kind of extrasensory
perception yeah that's like me just kind
of wheeling yeah like thoughts into your
head I guess but there's I'd say one of
the early things that you said and not
necessarily to me but just on the
podcast that you know like you say a lot
of stuff and it's kind of like and you
are essentially talking to me right
where you're sitting across talking to
me but one of the things you said was um
you already know the right thing to do
you just have to do it then I'm like ah
yeah I'm thinking like okay I heard that
before but but you start to think about
it I call man that's true huh you just
you just you know already it's not like
a big like mystery like you know it's
like water because kind of lame to know
the right thing to do and not do it
there has to be something to with the
fact that you're not just hearing me say
the words but you are a person that
actually sees what I'm doing on a daily
basis in a way yeah you know what I'm
doing
yeah you see what I'm doing so when I'm
saying that it's not like oh you
whatever what's that word drifted
through all right what's that called
scrolled through your Instagram feed and
someone said you already know what to do
just do it you're actually watching me
and saying oh yeah he's he knows what
he's supposed to do and he's doing yes
so and in here the here is when that
part became clear where the first time
okay so okay so I'm recording a podcast
let's say five episodes in we'll just
say no maybe it's more maybe it's less
but five episodes in it's like okay
that's five weeks every week now you're
and we're recording in my house and this
time and you'd come up and it was like
at night do we have to do it after Prezi
was asleep yeah after we and and you'd
come up we'd record him like cool and
then one time I'm like shoot is like
again again again and then you're coming
in with your notes and all this stuff
like man this guy is like Brad this
guy's no quit cuz it was like you can be
doing the coolest funnest thing but when
it's like coming again and again and
again you're like whoa let me let me
take a rest between sets here a little
bit you know but nope not you you're
just rolling in and then after a while
when when I start getting used to it
that's what I'd like sort of reflect
like men if you weren't here doing this
right now if I let's say I filled my
little weirdo dream of having a podcast
and that's my job I don't think I would
I don't think I would have done it as
much as often for sure I would have
started it's like slowing down or
whatever because there would be times
where I'd be like man maybe we should
just take this week off kind of thing
it's not like it's this crazy hard work
and just it's just that's sort of how it
is but it seems like that didn't faze
you at all I remember one time I had a
gig on the East Coast and I flew and
then I had another gig on the East Coast
and I had what
a day in between and we and we own a
podcast and I flew back to San Diego
we went recorded the podcast and I flew
back out to the east coast yeah yeah and
I said hmm that's what we're doing here
yeah in this podcast god yeah man and
that's it's like that is so such a for
lack of a better term like so I'm so
lucky in that way because like that
that's not like a rare thing where
you're hanging around with someone and
they rub off on you you know where you
knew all this stuff but since the person
right next to you is doing it then you
start to do it you know it's like like
jujitsu you know you hear about Jesus we
know about Jesus or whatever but it's
like what if like your brother starts
doing jujitsu or whatever or the people
at work start doing jujitsu then you go
check this out it like it kind of
influences you you know in that way so
it's lucky that like Ana this is every
week not to mention all the training
jiu-jitsu so I'm around you more and
we're talking about it and its new and
exercise so we're always talking about
so oh yeah man I was just primed for
influence at that time so at that point
I was like yeah man he's really doing it
and going back to you already know the
right thing to do you just have to do it
me know so I'm like okay and then I see
you doing it so that influenced me to
like really take that into consideration
as far as like daily conscious thought
you know so so then that what did that
actually turn into as far as action wise
okay first I stopped drinking and here's
hey I didn't stop drinking but I stopped
drinking where that was like a habit so
I stopped that and so you went from just
used to juice to drink every day every
day yeah how often you drink now well
there's no like often like sometimes
we'll drink sometime they won't but yeah
once a month once a week some day yes
like sometimes none a month zero a month
but then sometimes like three times a
week whatever and this is just how it
shook itself out like now it's not a
habitual thing every night you know it's
just it's more of it yeah I can maneuver
my way through any like drinking
scenario you know and I don't even know
if I was like addicted like an alcoholic
I mean maybe technically on paper or
something maybe but it was a kind and it
was basically this if I had three and I
think I told this before where there was
three factors with
drinking a lot and that was if I was
undisturbed meaning by like my family or
any like obligations you know like I got
to drive somewhere or take care of the
kids or whatever undisturbed its meaning
you if you had no responsibilities at a
certain time certain time yeah so that's
an opportunity to drink and a likelihood
drink yes okay that was a factor of
putting on it and then the other one was
obviously alcohol present right and then
the third one was being in front of my
computer that was it if any of those
with one or more of those three factors
were not there like I wouldn't drink I'm
not compelled to drink at all you know
like I'm not against drinking like I'll
go out and drink sake or some whatever
but it was a non-factor but if you get
those three especially back then if I
had those three present which was
essentially every night the kids go to
bed
you know I don't have to wake up early
for something specific or whatever um my
computer and it's weird cuz it wasn't my
laptop when I'm traveling or something
like that it was like my home computer
it's weird but if those three things
were present like you saw is pretty much
uncontrollable so then what was it that
broke that that that thing like you're a
thing where it's like you know the right
thing to do you just gotta do you know
like and this is I think always gonna be
the case I'm sure it's something has to
do with your brain but like you can know
the right thing to do you can do you
know huh but you oh it's almost like you
oversimplify it you're like hey how do
you wake up early wake up early you know
but a real person will be like how do I
wake up early okay yeah I wake up early
yeah that's where I want to get how do I
do that you're like yeah I just do it
it's like you're skipping all these like
mental loses and acrobatics that normal
people do on like emotions and have it
and like all this like stuff that we
have to sort of go through to get there
you know cuz we like certain comforts in
fact not only do we like them it's like
we can sort of need them in in a little
bit a little bit of yourself right
exactly right and you kind of
oversimplify it so coming from someone
just telling you that oh yeah I just
wake up early you're like okay like I
shouldn't even have asked you because
essentially in a way it's not really
what I'm asking like I know that part
like how do I get there how do I make
that part like more accessible or that
ability more accessible to myself that's
kind of what they're asking but
meanwhile like I'm watching you do all
these things and it's kind of like
that's how you are you just oversimplify
it kind of thing like you just alright
I'm just gonna do it granted there's
more to it but like what I'm seeing you
just do it so I guess I'm just gonna do
it then and then you do it then it's
kind of coffee right should have done
that like 10 years ago that is literally
how simple it is granted
it'll make it'll be just as simple or
just as complex and hard and um you know
slippery of a situation as as you make
as you allow it to be yeah
and allow it yeah
but when you kind of when I think back
on it for myself I'm like making it
complicated it like putting effort into
making a car and I still do it that's
the Hamburglar it's one step further
than allowing it to be me making a
comment I think that's all most of us
are that's the thing so okay so here's
another thing that I learned when you're
like oh and it does go back to just you
know the right things you just do it
regarding out right so I working I like
to work you know weightlifting and stuff
I sort of liked it
you know sort of one of those things
look for it but you know I see it all do
you have other responsibilities all this
stuff you don't necessarily like it as
much but you know it's good for you and
all this stuff so there was a point
where it was really easy to just define
skip workouts let's do it tomorrow
whatever because they don't feel like it
I can get enough rest or I'm doing this
other thing or whatever right but if
you're just like hey you know it needs
to be done you just do it don't think
about it don't think about but that's
not really how my brain work my brain
worked where I was I was kind of
dependent on that that that good feeling
of looking forward to working out and
getting fired up and working out I was
kind of dependent on that feeling you
don't realize it but it's there fully
were you dependent on it so you're just
like yeah you just don't think about
just do it but I'm like wait but but I
really don't feel like it you know like
that's just a given I don't feel like
that's a given part of the equation so
then what I would do is okay I'll just
do it but not do it like I just do it
as in workout I just do it as you try to
get fired up and try to get myself
motivating get get fired up to do this
stuff but that's not that's not how it
works you ski you don't you don't work
harder to get that unnecessary part of
it into the equation you can if it were
free but but that's not the point you
were that I took from it the point is
you skip that but you just go work out
just do it you know kind of thing I
think it's so simple when I'm like
saying it out loud that's a good
connection to make a good connection to
make with when it's like just go do the
activity it's not just it's not hey just
force yourself to get fired up just
force yourself no yeah because you can't
even do that
yes yes I can try but why waste the
energy on that just go do the activity
that you're supposed to do yeah and then
another thing is like you make a good
play it's like a lot of this stuff is
just sort of there and you're just there
to like grab my hand and like be like
here see this see the thing you've been
seeing this whole time you know that's
crazy
okay so when you're learning to do have
you ever learned something in jiu-jitsu
we cannot believe that you couldn't
figure that out that you didn't figure
that out I'll give you an example here's
a real simple example
you're mounted on someone and they start
to push your knee or with their hand or
their elbow to start an elbow escape I
remember like people would do this to me
I mean I'm I'm a wipeout maybe even I'm
a blue belt mmm and I think I asked Dean
I'm like hey Dean what do you do when
they start pushing and he goes oh so he
does it to me or he you know he mounts
me he goes here push my knee so I start
pushing his knee he reaches down on this
hand pulls it off yeah and and and the
answer was so obvious and this is one of
hundreds of examples and I'm not the
smartest guy in the world but I'm not
that stupid either and for me to not be
able to figure out certain things it
shows you that if you can't it shows you
that there's certain things that can be
right in front of your face and you just
don't see them and I think that's what
you're talking about
like I'm not holding your
I'm just going hey no no wait let me
show you exactly what to do here you
just do this yeah it's like oh yeah and
there's a lot you know there's I've
heard many people have told me that
that's what they got from the podcast or
that that's what they got from extreme
ownership or their economy leadership or
the discipline equals freedom Field
Manual they're like I always thought
that I always knew that I mean I was
just with the Australian when we were at
the monster you know an Australian guy
that was in the military for what a long
time and he said yeah when I read when I
read your book I was like yes you just
put into words what I the way I've been
trying to lead and the good thing about
that is you have the idea in your head
of what's good but you don't necessarily
codify it where you can now say yes this
is the answer so that that's a it's a
big step it's like occasionally you
randomly pull the hand that's getting
you in the mouth you might do it
occasion but you don't actually know it
and identify it as something you can do
whereas once you go when someone's doing
that here's the reaction bunk do so
there's there's a definite plus to that
yeah and in that rabbit hole of like
revelations like that is is endless
keeps like going and going and going and
in certain things you sort of forget to
you know cuz you know a human being
we're all human beings with habits and
stuff like that so you forget certain
ones or whatever but man it's like
they're everywhere everywhere so even
like the whole just the whole concept of
if you don't feel like doing it but you
need you know that it has to get needs
to get done or whatever or even just
that you want it to be done but you
don't feel like it just that just
excluding the part that you don't feel
like it just doing that seems like super
simple and he or it seems easy it is
very simple it seems like pretty easy
when you say it and then when you go
through it it's it seems so hard but the
weird that and this is nothing new where
once you once you get it done like okay
so an email right no you may or may not
go through this but a lot of us got this
where it's like you have this nagging
email of someone that you have to
respond to someone and to respond to
them you need certain information and to
get that information you got to go
reopen some files and stuff like that so
it'll take two minutes two minutes
not even two minutes but you got a your
brain has to stop thinking this way it
has to pivot and change these weird
directions and do all this other stuff
right now
so you took man I don't feel like doing
that right now I'm doing this other
stuff or I'm just not doing that right
now I'll do it tomorrow do it later
today whatever and then it winds up
being like weeks and meanwhile still
there they you know still they're
hanging over your head hanging over your
head then you're like I can talk about
that on the warrior kid podcast letting
your homework hang over your head yeah
okay actually there's some kids apply to
know what hang over your head of kind of
kind of explain what that means yes
because when someone's hanging over your
head what are you waiting you're waiting
for that thing to hit you so you don't
want that you've got when you get home
from school do your homework don't let a
hangover it ruins their whole night so
that you know it's gonna ruin your whole
night your whole dink your whole life
you know life so any not in this huge
way but it'll be nagging yes like you
know it's kind of like when you're
sleeping and you gotta use bathroom and
you're like oh you don't want to get
stand-up just go just good anyway so
meanwhile okay then finally you're like
you know what finally I feel like you
know finally I can't take it anymore
finally it's irritating it's irritating
me enough so I'll do it you go in the
email you take care of thing you do it
it takes two minutes or whatever you're
done you're like why did I just do that
a long time ago I wouldn't have felt any
of that stress or whatever and so but
habitually going into that mode where
it's like okay this needs to get done I
don't care how I feel I'm just gonna do
it real quick like that in and of itself
is a habit is a way you know is it a way
of thinking that at the very least so if
that was something that I got better at
as well mm-hmm the other thing that's
been interesting well interesting from
my perspective is that you are de facto
detached during this whole thing so you
get to be I mean first of all even when
if I'm covering a book I mean you're
listening but you get to kind of observe
me reading the book thinking about the
book talking about the book when we have
guests on a lot of times you don't say
anything and you're just completely
getting to observe this whole thing
unfold from the outside so you could I
know I've we've gotten done with some
pot
and someone would ask me say like well
how was that like one of our guests
would say how was it and I'll look at
you and say how was it cuz I'm in it and
you have a better perspective because
you are literally detached and watching
it
I mean I'm somewhat detached but I'm
also reading writing thinking engaging
answering so I'm doing all those things
and I'm detached from that enough you
know I've detached from it enough that I
can guide the conversation I'm detached
from enough that I'm not getting too
emotional or too stuck on something or I
mean let's let's face it there's been
some danger close calls for those
emotions are creeping up you know
sitting across from a from a guy that's
you know what I've been through whatever
and you're bringing those emotions back
out of them and I mean it can get
dangerous for sure and sometimes I got
to do a little detachment to keep it
real but you all and sometimes I do a
better job than you do because because
you'll be over the court or you'll be
sitting in your chair you know and I
gotta I gotta try and keep it together
yeah cuz you're not so but that's
sometimes sometimes you get wrapped up
in the emotions of the story yourself
especially if it has to do with kids and
you kind of lose the bubble and but
other than those moments a lot of times
you're sitting there just listening and
you're detached so you kind of get to
you kind of get a great perspective of
it which is nice yes sir
yeah I'd say I'm like maybe 60% maybe
50% detached because I'm like I'm the
audience member just like everybody else
really like when you're talking about
stuff and or when you're interviewing
someone like men I'm enjoying the show
like everybody else but I'm like in the
show as well you know so as an audience
member will say uh that's how I can
evaluate hey that was a good show or
like bro what do you used to even
talking about right now nothing that
it's ever happened I'm not saying it has
you know but um the end that's why it is
you know so yeah I will be affected by
these things and but then I'll be
affected even more because yes I am part
of it
like I'm in it you know I'm sitting
there across from you guys um but yes
yeah because when you're talking um
whatever you or even like let's say when
I'm I'm talking you even right now like
there's a few things sort of rolling in
my brain like okay sure I say what I'm
gonna say my little idea and it comes
out but then there's like a post talk
thought is always saying yeah exactly
like a little bit like [__] am I saying
the right thing you know
or did that sound dumb it's like it's
just a constant like small like humming
evaluation kind of process that's going
on and then it's like okay like do I
want to interrupt
at this point cuz I have a thought but
no I couldn't so I'm sort of minding my
P's and Q's as well you know so there's
all these little things that hold you in
and not it won't it'll kind of keep you
from being detached but I don't have
that when I'm not saying anything you
know but yeah even you I mean I would
imagine you're you kind of have the same
thing you know you have to run this you
have to yeah I gotta think about what
I'm saying at the same time this is a
visitor dichotomy of that if you think
about what you're saying too much it's
not very good it's just like jujitsu
right if you're thinking about a move
it's too late if you if you're analyzing
what you're gonna say before it comes
out of your mouth to make sure that's
the right thing where you you're it's
not not the right thing to do at the
same time you can't just go verbal
diarrhea and just start spewing stuff
out because now you now you may say some
stuff that you shouldn't say you know so
there's a little little game that you
have to play you have to you have to
kind of assess that stuff you have to be
detached when you're doing it to make
sure that you don't say something stupid
and you can't say stupid stuff I mean I
I think about the amount of interviews
I've done and and just like you you
never know when it's gonna come I'm sure
at some point I'm gonna say something go
yes I wouldn't have said that I should
have never said that because you it is
what it is yeah and you could I mean and
it makes sense to where you can you can
have a certain thought and then there's
like how do you say that thought right
like how do you how do you articulate
your thoughts right and to expect or to
think that like if you have a thought
it'll be perfectly articulated or
whatever those don't go hand in hand you
know some people are super good at it
like in fact you're like you're one of
the better people that I've written
anyway that at that probably you know
probably could he keep things pretty
simple most of the time but at the same
time like you're not immune to that you
know so sometimes like your articulation
of a certain thought will come off like
different you know it'll come off like
it might even be accurate but then the
way it'll land on people will be like
okay and I'm not saying this it
necessarily has happened I'm saying this
this type of stuff can't happen so it'll
be like oh yeah you came off as like
insensitive or you don't understand or
you're racist or you're you know like
all these interpretations that seem like
reasonable interpretations given the
words that you said but it's like man
that was just I shouldn't have said it
that way cuz it's not quite as accurate
as what I think you know so yeah you
gotta constantly monitor that little gem
yuh-huh
there is it for that yeah what about in
terms of relationships like your wife
what have you taken away take it man
does your wife does your wife like you
more now yeah or before I think I think
she likes me more now put it this way
like I I like our relationship better
now and that's saying a lot because like
we have a good we already had a good
relationship you know like I was one of
these we're like these people who we
knew each other before we started dating
like we knew it so there was no like you
can you can get in you can jam yourself
up I think sometimes like if you jump
into a dating situation like super early
and then a marriage situation super
early and whatever like you can jam
yourself up I'm the same no this happens
but you can and I'm not saying if you
know someone for a long time it taking
so I'm not saying that's a perfect like
solution I'm not saying that but in our
case we took it like super slow so there
was like we had a solid foundation have
a solid foundation so the point there we
had a good relationship but you know
like any relationship there's like
arguments and you know I'm so sandy I'm
sorry I shouldn't have acted like that
you know there's like way less of that
like because I know like habitually how
to how to act you know so okay so
extreme ownership right extreme
ownership perfect that goes deep it's
that's a concert like that Ravenel right
there is like
at first when you first like get
introduced to it like oh yeah everything
then you're like yeah okay make sense
cool I thought that yeah yeah yeah it's
the concept the ownership don't blame I
get it right but there's like so many
levels of blaming so many there's like
the overt like you should have done this
like blaming right the kind I think it I
say it I'm blaming 100% then there's
like oh you know it's not your fault but
inside your head you're like it's your
fault you know so that'll drive certain
other like subsequent like behavior you
know then there's like okay I know I'm
supposed to take I'm you're thinking
this Aryan I'm supposed to take extreme
ownership so I'm not gonna blame them so
it's not your it's my fault you know but
meanwhile your behavior doesn't like
take full responsibility because kind of
sort of quote-unquote deep down you know
it's kind of and it just goes deeper and
deeper deep in here then you find out
all these little pockets of like non
extreme ownership you know that you have
and to me granted you know my life is
very specific but with your wife or I
guess kids but that's different but with
your wife is a good it's a good
battlefield to to test that out and to
learn about it because it can get so
emotional you know like yeah and you
don't really have a break from it you
know it's like at work it's like cool
that didn't work even if I messed up I
can still go home to my lovely family or
go out to the bar I I have a break from
it you know with your wife it's like you
don't have a break from it it's like you
got to perform you know that you gotta
it kind of means a lot it matters a lot
so I think it works good but at the same
time you guys both have a commitment to
be there so it's like you can get cut
some slack most of the time obviously it
depends on your wife but in my case
that's how it was so what I sort of
discovered and continue to discover like
just how good it works just how good
like extreme ownership just and
everything that comes with it you know
like not blaming all the little tips
that you'll say like um what is the one
we're like what do you say absorbing
something you know when they come at you
with something that happened to them
like you totally like that oh man man
golden ticket right there man so good
even like and that reflect and diminish
in fact you can even use it in like you
can just reflect Oh for you even have to
diminish just jump up if it doesn't mean
anything you know just jump on our side
right now you know well yeah you can
jump on the side the thing is with the
reason that diminish is important on
reflect and diminish is because if you
can fuel the fire even more what you
want to move towards as a solution you
want to you want to de-escalate the
situation yeah
but the best way to do that is to
reflect the emotions that they're
showing and then diminish them a little
bit so that they come so that they're on
your side yes but then they start to
calm down yeah so you can like um you
can refer so that one when I just said
that is I'm thinking of like a few
different scenarios where I'll just
refer I won't even diminish until like
the next day or something oh so
essentially it's really anybody but I'll
just reflect it so then did reflect oh
man you know how how much it does for
your well I mean speaking about myself
I don't know but no it's true and and by
the way you're talking about this from a
marriage perspective I'm talking about
it from from a leadership perspective
but and they're the same thing they're
the same thing
but what's interesting is you just said
you know how good this is and you're
right and you know what you got to be
careful of that because it's an easy way
to bond with someone is they come in and
say the boss sucks and you go yeah the
boss sucks that's actually not the right
thing to do right you don't want to
disparage your boss what you want to say
is you know you want it but you don't
want to say no the boss is awesome
because now you're at enemies right but
when the person says oh the boss sucks
and you say you know I'm not really sure
where they're making this decision from
okay now you're talking about decision
so you're giving them a little bit of
reflection you're diminishing a little
bit so you can have a real conversation
about what's going on yeah yeah so
there's a certain scenario that that is
comes up a lot this scenario literally
means nothing at the end of the day so
and you'll get the award in my life
I'll get these from time to time work so
for example my way like many ways watch
reality TV from time to time and you
know it's the Real Housewives of this or
married to medicine or whatever right
these these are TV
and they're like boo depends on your
opinion but you know they're in my
opinion wanted to let most like the
lamest type of show but whatever
shreya is goals they throw them together
and they're all rich and super immature
and doing dumb stuff and yelling and
sounds like awesome no they're great TV
so but here's the thing you know when
there's like a sort of it you know when
we're just sort of cruising or relaxing
or whatever and and it's on this is what
I used to do back in the day where I'd
be like like what is this sure the show
is dumb like this is seeing you
disparage her the thing that she likes
right and I mean that's not what I'm
meaning resumed you're disparaging her
oh yeah oh yeah but I didn't mean to do
that no more like I'm talking about the
show you know spin truthful for being
truthful exactly you know we're just
using radical candor yeah but meanwhile
she did I mean she wouldn't get mad but
every once in a while she'd be like hey
just leave me alone you know like I
don't I don't you know talk trash about
your shows you know I don't give you
issue she was like I don't insult you
you know about your shows or whatever
meanwhile I'm thinking like keep in mind
sometimes watch MacGyver and these types
of shows right so I don't really have
much of a leg to stand on but in my head
I'm like yeah cuz my shows are awesome
kind of thing you know
um and the thing is I'm not doing
anything to her I'm talking about the
show you know kind of thing but just
like I you said it's like I'm
disparaging her taste and show her
choices like basically are laughter hold
so so I sort of start to realize that or
whatever so I did the whole reflect no
diminish cuz it's meaningless the show
and says me like I can disparage your
show in her all are what she's still
gonna like the show you know it's not
like she bases her life on it this is
literally meaningless so now she'll be
like oh my gosh she can't believe like
this lady did that I'm in the room so of
course it could literally be a cat in
the room she'd probably say the same
thing like she's just saying it to
someone right I can't believe I can't
believe she did this and she'll like
rewind it or whatever but like hell yeah
yeah she's so stupid like kind of like
I'm into the show you know everyone said
ah she'll catch it she Blake pay you
don't like the show or whatever but and
the thing is I don't but it's kind of
fun to do yeah and at the same time it's
like consider the difference
you know consider the difference be
saying oh my gosh don't you don't don't
rewind it I don't care about that's it
you know so it's like that kind of stuff
as well man where it's like you kind of
look it in you look at the whole
situation as far as like the big picture
you know where's like did--we do I make
it a point to make a point right now you
don't so that question for you yeah so
when you look broadly what's what's like
your most valuable thing that you've
kind of adopted into your life since we
started recording this podcast key
there's there at first there's one but
there's two things and they might play
off each other I guess but the main one
is the long game versus the short game
and and you said that to me early on
that I was like I would have never
thought of that given what you said it
about back then but the long game versus
the short game cells like man so that's
stuck in my head and since then I
realized every little move you make
literally like in like I don't care if
it's like you're going to store to go
buy some I don't know paper towels or
something dude
it's like there's always a long game and
a short game in play right now
so anything and if you think about it
anything that you're successful at it's
like you you're at least playing the
long game some things in life people
just aren't even playing the game
they're just going a minute-to-minute
you know and that's a that's short you
know you you caught this at one of the
musters a guy asked how often are you
thinking strategically which thinking
strategically is thinking a long game
here and you you caught a clip of me
getting a little bit fired up of saying
you know I'm thinking strategic Oh time
that's let and that's the truth that is
the way you should look at every
decision that you make why would you
make a decision based on the short term
how come
being positive it if it has a negative
long term effect you just shouldn't do
that you got to play the long game
and I'll tell you like I am thinking
strategic all the time
and that is so beneficial is so
beneficial in everything that you do and
yet it's easy to get suckered in to
making short-term decisions based on
short-term gratification but based on
the ease of movement based on a path of
least resistance based on what's gonna
feel good right now based on even what's
gonna produce good results right now
look we hope that our immediate results
are aligned with our long-term results
in something that benefits us right now
will benefit benefit us in the long run
that's a great opportunity that does
happen sometimes but sometimes
oftentimes short-term gains will resent
result in long-term losses so you got to
think through this in everything that
you do yeah and I remember one when that
guy asked that question and I remember
thinking to myself that that's
interesting it kind of became clear why
that's not so obvious and there's
obvious reasons why for sure because
when he asked the when asked the
questions like huh because when even
when you put it in those terms like
strategic versus tactical right tactical
is the short-term game strategic is the
long-term yeah even so when you put when
you use those specific words okay so how
often are you thinking strategic it's
almost like he gives this feeling it's a
feeling that you're like plotting you
know how often are you plotting meaning
you have a certain plot in mind you know
like but it doesn't mean that like
that's one maybe possible way of seeing
it but I don't talking about that like
everything is like a game like you're
moving through life you know so what
where's your aim gonna kind of sort of
be and those those aims those goals for
lack of better term or literally
everything you do like you otherwise why
what are you been doing why would even
move a muscle you know if you don't have
like an aim to do it or whatever and
that aim is gonna be there long term or
short term we both can be both for sure
and that's like the that's it's rare but
that's really a good opportunity as you
put it but even if like you stand it
like you're sitting there right not
moving a muscle
right we'll say it's good extreme
example and you're like okay I gotta
move on
so right maybe because I'm getting stiff
or whatever there's always some like
goal that you gotta sort of achieve and
if you look at everything like that and
you consider okay what what's the
ultimate outcome that I want you know
and you could just keep that in mind
man that is like a life life-changing
thing when you can really understand
that I think that is a good one another
thing that I told the story when we hit
one time on this podcast and you
mentioned it to me I was talking about
how when I was young I was in the seal
platoon and I was thinking I was all
awesome and all of a sudden like other
guys were getting promoted other guys
were moving into better positions than
me and I've kind of looked at myself and
I said if you're so smart then why
aren't you winning and that was a big
step for me to come to that realization
and and what's good about it is that's
another kind of early indicator of
taking ownership because instead of me
saying look come I'm smart and I'm not
winning cuz everyone else is against me
because this guy is that and this guy's
an ass kisser and this guy you know all
that could have done that instead I
looked at myself and said wait a second
if you're so smart and and luckily for
me some of the guys around me or good
guys they were my friends they I knew
that they were I couldn't blame anything
on them but if I was so smart why wasn't
I winning yeah that's the other thing oh
that's the other that's the other
hundred percent and you know you see it
in people and like like a lot of these
things just like extreme ownership like
you can see it in other people super
clear you know like this guy's talking a
lot of trash for being a loser and you
know kind of thing you know like you
know the old thing where it's like oh
yeah I'm getting read this guy's giving
me relationship advice and when he's
like a single person you know he doesn't
have a successful relationship or
whatever you know like that kind of
stuff it's super easy to see that in
other people but for yourself it's like
yeah man I have this cool idea that you
probably got from someone else or
whatever and you have this quite doing
either you're so quick to be to tell
people about it and to correct this
person you know because it's so obvious
they're doing it wrong right so you're
gonna correct them and boom boom and you
have your arguments and debates all like
formulated perfectly way in any debate
meanwhile you're not doing anything you
know if you
six order it so that is a big deal like
what I realized that that's a huge deal
like it and it's way better just to be
quiet man
you gotta end it and it kind of like how
you guys start part of the monster you
dandy Berk they'll good deal day you'll
talk about like taking action right so
it's like taking action part it's like
the hardest part of whatever right it's
like the guy who goes to school so much
so much and then it's like but he can't
really function the real world because
his whole focus on is ongoing to school
yeah or the person watching like a bunch
of motivational videos and he's just all
he's motivated to do is watch more
motivational videos he doesn't take any
action or what everybody's dopamine from
a won motivational video do I do people
yeah yeah yeah so that's that's what
that's what makes I'm gonna want want to
go watch another one what's more yeah
yeah hell yeah yeah they're like two
things you know like two separate
separate things but nonetheless it it
kind of brings all that into perspective
you know like you you if you're not in
or if you're so smart why aren't you
winning so with the why aren't you
winning prep that's the most important
part you know like it's almost like bra
who cares how smart that person is you
ever you ever hear someone hate on
someone like oh they're just dumb or
whatever like uh who's won the Kim
Kardashian right you know people hate on
her they're like I'm not even saying
necessarily that I feel this way but I'm
saying this is what plays out a lot of
times they'll hate on her she's so dumb
and they're so dumb or whatever and then
it's like alright but if you're so not
dumb like why is she like winning you
know you're sort of not you know kind of
thing it's like that whole idea is there
is got put into perspective very much so
it's like that's always on my mind to
like before I opened my mouth or
whatever it's like bro you before you
open your mouth you should really work
on a bunch of stuff first
so that's yeah that's a big one and it
helps a lot too because you start to
focus on doing rather than blabbing you
know and platon I don't mean just blimey
I mean everywhere like on social media
all these people having their strong
opinions you know it's crazy I know I I
see that happen right you know like I
when I was on with Joe
and tulsi gabbard you know obviously
there was there's she's a she's
literally running for president United
States of America okay cool
and there's obviously we touched on we
didn't really like to have a debate by
any stretch I mean we we both we both
kind of talked about things and we all
kind of talked about things as human
beings that were whatever you know is
pretty straightforward right but the the
conversations that took place on Twitter
after that I mean we're talking just I I
I was I was like man you is this the
best place for this random person to
have this major debate with some other
random person about whatever topic had
come up that was either you know they
didn't agree with or they agreed with so
I think it's a little crazy sometimes oh
yeah I hear people say you know that
Twitter is just the most horrible thing
to participate in right and I don't
really think it's a horrible thing in
fact I've gotten great interactions on
Twitter I've gotten incredible feedback
I've met people I mean the whole reason
that I was on with Joe and Tulsi was
because of Twitter but books I've linked
up with people we've had people on the
podcast that I never would have heard of
or never would have been introduced to
that that are American heroes that have
incredible stories that that's all
through Twitter I've gotten great
feedback I've gotten adjustments I've
gotten correct so that's all good but
yeah if you're gonna go down the hole of
like hey let's debate this hot
controversial topic you know it's hard
for me to to to reflect on that in a
positive way you know it's like hard for
me to look at someone go man
this is what you you know you just sent
out nine tweets like link you know you
can link
together and someone will send out nine
tweets about some topic and it just
worries me because I think there's more
productive things that people could do
with their time like if you know if you
want to put those things together in an
organized way and you want to make those
statements and almost always there
attacking like in a super aggressive
personal attack as well so anyways it's
just interesting yeah it says a lot like
the word say what they say but like the
fact that those words are there like
says a whole nother thing you know like
you know though nothing new where it's
like man you don't have anything better
to do than to like express and it's not
like a lot any by any logical means
they'd come to the conclusion that yeah
what I say is gonna like solve whatever
problem is that I'm addressing you know
whatever like there's no reason to think
that yeah I I guess I'm trying to think
of a good metaphor for me this is like a
metaphor if you saw someone that was
having a that was shouting at but at a
toilet at the top of their lungs and and
they walk out of that stall kind of like
oh yeah you know kind of like yeah and
and I'm thinking man you just you just
yelled because that's what that's what
it is right you're yelling at a toilet
because whoever doesn't wanna listen you
isn't gonna be even gonna read the
little things that you wrote so once
once again that's why it's more what's
more important is like why not find some
common ground with someone from a
leadership reform just from a leadership
perspective right from a leadership
perspective I want to find common ground
with someone I want to figure out what
it is that they think what their
perspective is that I can understand
their perspectives so that I can
actually give them a logical argument or
at least show them what I believe to be
valid points so that they can then give
me feedback on those points and I can
learn from them and either adjust my
position or adjust their position you
can't get that done when you're yelling
at a toilet which is
a lot of people end up doing so but yeah
that and also that reminds me as well
and another is a little bit more of a
detail than anything but like how you
tell you do the dole but the musters you
call it being a tactical genius I mean
just be quiet and let everyone else talk
kind of thing and this like I find way
more prevalent when I hear two people
talk they're talking they're debating
and there's little differences in
differences and then you can kind of you
know like you detach from it right but
you actively did that because man before
I was strongly compelled to like jump in
and like correct you you're wrong here
and let me correct you right cuz I'm
smart right gotta prove it to these
people and prove I'm down down for this
whole thing I'm smart right
so a soul quick to like jump in and be
like yeah you know that's wrong that's
correct and let me expand on that kind
of thing you know and it's fun to do you
know it's a you know you're having
conversations whatever I dig it but
there's a bigger picture you know so if
you don't say anything you can see that
bigger picture
you can be like right you know how
annoying you're being right now like
you're I think you're saying like
truthful stuff or whatever but you're
beat there's a bigger picture with what
you're doing so your tactics might be
good your strategy is awful it's way on
a long name is weak you're gonna win
this argument and you're gonna make this
person dig in deeper that's what's gonna
happen not to mention like you less yeah
after this like you think you're
impressing them with the and I'm just
thinking of like very specific
conversations that that I'm remembering
right now whether it be friends or
whatever friend family but you kind of
think to yourself man like I used to
talk to my brother about this idea where
it's like man what you're saying is
correct in your little debate but about
what you're doing is wrong you can't do
that or you can but you're gonna lose
your war whatever so yeah so one the one
of the things I learned that's just with
me right now just with me hardcore is
just don't say anything just be the
tactical genius so when they ask you
when they look at you or what you do for
whatever like strategic reason wanna
chime man yeah you're like you're way
more in a position of that you want to
be in you know and you you don't run the
risk of being all sucked in and
alienating people
doing all the things that that you've
run the risk of doing when you're you
know trying to impress them with how
smart you are and how good your position
is you know all right so let's get to
your black belt yes sir
you were surprised yes we did a good job
of keeping it under wraps yeah
but had you at this point just
surrendered the fact that you made we
just were gonna be a brown belt for a
really long time
yeah and part of this part of it was
like I'm glad I thought of it this way
and part of it is like Manish you know
you always think back on things like I
you should have handled things or
whatever soul could so moving up in
ranks and and I say this kind in a way
is it advice to maybe people who can
fall into these psychological traps with
the belt right they want a belt they
want that straw right or the blue belt
or the purple you know they want they
want to get promoted right because they
want to win part of it is because they
want to wear that belt and it doesn't
keep in mind it does not help
jiu-jitsu doesn't help users react
differently does not help this
particular situation where you know when
in our school I don't like you so I
thought you're saying it does not help
like oh definitely no no I thought
you're saying hey getting your black
belt by the way it does not help your
jujitsu which I was like thank you
that's a great belt does not make your
jujitsu any better nope might even
introduce the idea that it's not nearly
as good as you thought it was but yes oh
yeah I'll tell you about that too by the
way
but I'm saying the culture of jujitsu
doesn't help your think your mindset
about this especially like our school
doesn't do this a lot where you know how
they light everyone line up at the end
or the beginning classes and is like hey
by belt you white belts you go in the
back on the back go suckers you know no
sirs and subhuman Brett whatever you
guys these averages oh yeah and oh the
black belt not not even in the front row
in front of everybody you're facing man
yeah you know you guys bow down in front
of us kind of thing right and then okay
if you're a brown belt you're almost
here so you can come close right
everyone else in the back you know so
it's like I dig it man I did that the
jiu-jitsu culture does not help but if
you can kind of get past that
um this is how ideally I would have
tried to think about it where you like
okay so you the belt doesn't matter okay
so when I was coming up I didn't know
there was a dolt
like I I didn't really know I watched
UFC one two three four you know those
ones ensure high school wearing a belt
but I joined nogi Dean so we don't wear
belts therefore no belts I don't know
I'm thinking back I didn't think about
this but I'm thinking that that's
probably my subconscious thought so one
day Brant to remember aunty was one of
the trainer's or whatever he was like
you guys are about white belts here and
it was me and a group and I was like
white belts I never thought of that you
know so doing tournaments and
competitions and stuff like that after
it was a year like twelve thirteen
months right Jimmy remember Jimmy
Sanchez he was like hey come to class
tomorrow
and I was like I think no I can't come
tomorrow it was at 6:00 or whatever I
work I work at night so I can't come and
he was like no no no come tomorrow come
tomorrow you have to come tomorrow I
don't like but I can't come tomorrow
I don't know how else to tell you like I
can't come tomorrow not trained to her
he's like no no we're having promotions
tomorrow so I'm like I'm thinking I'm
not thinking belt promotions I don't
know about that yet so she's like you
still didn't realize no had no idea and
he he goes uh he said no we're having
promotions but I'm thinking you know how
like promotions like a tap out is coming
in to promote oh yeah it's like a show
that's what I'm thinking so and everyone
comes and it's a fun thing I thought it
was like a teen thing or something now
I'm like that's cool
and man if I didn't work that'd be cool
and I would Iike they say problem it's
like what I got it - I think you're
getting he goes you're getting promoted
tomorrow - blue belt I was like huh blue
belt because I never worry before I was
on no G so he's just didn't dawn on me
so like okay now it's only after like 13
months or whatever so let's just focus
on training and learning cool new moves
and oh my gosh we can do this now and
all that you know and getting better and
that's what I was focused on learning
and stuff then I got a blue B I was like
cool but still noogie I was competing so
it's like the belt never really I'm just
I just want to win I just want to get
better and we
cuz if I don't win I lose tournaments
and in that that part sucks doesn't
matter what don't plus a noogie like I
said it's it's not belt-driven it's you
know time so and then I got purple belt
like another year like super fast and it
was like a surprise it was like alius
was there
Joel Tudor was there he was like rolling
and I did a little bit of ghee at this
time and I was we're doing G and then
aleeah's just busts out a purple belt
and he's like giving it to me or
whatever and I was like huh this is
pretty kind of surprising and kind of
crazy but I started to do more Yi and
then I got hurt like at the end of
purple belt and and you know people were
starting to look at me like hey when are
you getting get your brown belt and
started getting introduced to me so that
my mindset kind of started to shift then
I stopped competing - so now like just
competing to win wasn't really part of
it it was it was all about walking in
the training room or this corrupt in the
moment into my mind so walk in the
training room you know I'm a purple belt
but I've been a pro belt for a while so
like I want to be a brown belt well I'm
better than that guy you know like I
tapped that guy out I should be I should
be wearing the brown belt standing up
front a little bit more you know it's
that starts to creep in meanwhile all
the stuff that got Gotti there you know
like focusing on like learning new moves
getting better at your moves and being
effective or whatever that is like sort
of secondary you know you kind of focus
like all my instructors here now let me
um I better not get caught
I better not experiment I better like
Shawn I'm good you know it's like that
and it jams you up so and then that's
not to mention the frustration when it
doesn't happen day after day week after
week and don't let there be a promotion
and you not get promoted harsh man harsh
luckily that never happened to me but
like I seen people like behave in ways
that you should never be even just used
to after that happens to him you know
the kind like a promotion goes on and
promoted and they don't you know so
anyway but I so I can imagine the
feeling right and then it and jemmye up
I felt like my learning just didn't like
a plateaued like pretty hardcore what
year is this this is like end of purple
belt which what year is that I got from
my brother militant 12 2012 okay so
there is that
um and then you know after you kind of
get promoted then everything starts to
come into perspective you know like man
I shouldn't waste my time thinking like
that all this up but you're kind of easy
now that you have the brown belt that
you wanted the whole time kind of thing
right so you kind of let it go
and then especially because brown belt
is kind of legit yeah I mean brown belt
islets is legit yeah and you're a
complete you know yeah you're you're
yeah it's a real thing yeah it's a I
think you're seriously in the game yes
you have game yes like you can
technically be a purple belt and really
maybe not have that great I mean look
there's purple balls out there that are
murderers for sure but you can you can
be a purple bottle be like yeah you know
and of course there's cases where this
is completely untrue but usually a brown
belt is legit like a 90 I guess for
every belt it goes up like a percentage
of what the person was that what the how
legit what the chances are that this
person is totally is legit it has really
good jiu-jitsu at brown belt there's a
really high probability that you're
legit and you have really good jiu-jitsu
yeah that's a good way of putting it
where it's like for every because it's
it always feels that way when you're a
white belt and you get promoted to blue
belt um you're like man that's like
that's legit that's a big huge deal and
then when you promote the purple belt
it's so much of a bigger deal that it's
like oh my blue belt promotion was
awesome but like nothing compared to
this purple belt and then purple belt
too Brown is almost like you're becoming
an adult kind of thing you know so it's
like way bigger it's like cool purple
belt but brown belt you know and then of
course brown belt the black belts even
bigger you know Plus is like a added
little thing to the black belt but um so
you know it's easier to have clear
thoughts on what an added little thing
to the world being a black well yeah
well you get to stand up front and so
that's the thing one thing is when
you're a black belt now the percentage
of people that are that hat that don't
really have good jiu-jitsu that our
black belt is very very small
it's very very small having a black belt
in jujitsu means there's a 99% chance
that you are good at Jiu Jitsu yeah cuz
there's some people that whatever I
don't even know where they got the belts
from or whatever because what I don't
want to do is just blanket say everyone
that's a black belt is awesome because
that's not true right yeah yeah but
there's a really good chance they even
got some good do Jitsu a fear of black
belt yeah fully and so anyway the foot
so the point and then I never really ran
into that at brown belt even though I
was a brown belt for a long time like
seven years I was a brown belt that was
more because I had like career and I let
myself like not focus on jiu-jitsu you
know for a while then you know I got
hurt again like all this all this stuff
um you was always campaigning for you to
get your black belt Oh Greg Train yeah
my man yeah no he would and he's your
you're the guy that he'd be like hey I
was feeling good oh yeah yeah and you
know that's the classic that's where my
joke came from is when do you think he
should get his black belt like I'm
probably another six months and then he
probably asked me that five times you
know for two years for two years
yeah maybe even longer he was it and
then honestly part of it was you'd get
hurt yeah you got you got hurt at some
really bad timing to get hurt yeah
meaning it was really close like okay we
you know it was like okay we're almost
an eye person was almost in the planning
stages of like okay time to give him his
black belt yeah and I probably reached
that planning phase I might have reached
that planning phase I don't know have
you been hurt three times there bit
there old major injury was by at brown
belt bicep my knee L was out for a while
just probably my bicep going as far as
her injuries go yeah okay so there's
probably two times in there where it was
I was probably in the planning phase of
okay we need to make this happen
yeah and when you get hurt I'd be like
104 nothing happening now yeah you know
it's what I guess could be frustrating
but I I didn't feel it at the time when
I was in that happened with purple belt
as well cuz that day when I got hurt um
aleeah's told me hey you got it I was
really into noogie noogie
competition so I didn't want to do the
key part of it that was like an all-day
competition they'd be in the day and
then no get night and uh Ilyas was like
hey do the key part of it and I was like
no no that's not where my goals the
speech is like no no you should really
do the key it'll help your game all this
stuff so like I've been like cool man I
respect you and you're the man but my
goals don't look you know giving him
this sort of technical speech and he's
like it's kind of like how Jamie did me
a long time ago he's like bro do the key
cuz this geek competition is your brown
belt test straight up told me cuz you
want to do something like cool one
I won the purple got hurt in the noogie
no purple years and years and years ago
by no provel so same deal man like right
before that was he told you brown belt
or purple belt I was a purple well that
was that meant that geek competition
yeah yeah he didn't say if I want you
just said that's your test for to get
your Brown to get brown bow yeah just
changed it to a purple belt what do you
were you retold the story so yeah got it
yeah so that was the test and you had
success no promotion yeah cuz I got hurt
it's all the same deal but it's yeah
it's part of the game but in brown in
brown belt even those longer time and
you know what how that I'm thinking of
it and I had to stop before you the the
the the introduction and I guess it
wasn't an introduction but the
introduction of you taking a little bit
more like control over what belt I had
like one word um I don't know when
exactly that was but there's a time
where I'm where I'm thinking in fact
someone even told me maybe told someone
who eventually told me that like oh yeah
they're gonna Proactiv brown belt but
jock was standing in the way like jock
who won't let it happen
like the kind Dean was said like okay
and duck was like no that's what someone
told me I'm like a little bit of a
little bit of I mean the bottom line is
we we have a pretty actually someone did
tell me that exactly and I know it
doesn't matter pretty pretty democratic
promotional system here because we have
so many black belts everybody knows
different sides of people's games
so generally there'll be like a
hey what do you think I mean for the
lower belts it's sort of you know the
individual black belt instructor be like
hey I promoted this guy this guy but
when it comes to black belt there's
gonna be some consensus yeah now I will
say I am probably the biggest hurdle
yeah when it comes to black belt right
because this is a big deal so I'm not
over here throwing out black belts on
Greenville and going up yep good to go
so yeah I mean there were some times I
don't you know whether I was the only
guy standing in the way and part of it
is just the whole dynamics of the
situation which is you know someone
throws it out there not like hey I think
but someone being like hey you think
Echo's ready my standard answer is gonna
be back no it's not ready
probably yeah probably like six months
right probably pretty standard answer
whether that was you or whoever so yeah
there's probably some facts to me being
the world roadblock yeah but not because
not because I was like I don't want to
give echo his black belt that wasn't it
at all it's like I want echo to be to
deserve his black belt Yeah right that's
what I always felt too and I was ready
yeah we'll put simply you had a specific
standard that wasn't a that was not a
flimsy standard that was like for the
real deal and I saw I figured that and
with varying levels and mixed emotions
about that because you know the immature
side of me is like like man just just
let it go bro you know like wait you
gotta be such a hard-ass all the time
kind of attitude and then the other side
is like man it's almost like logical
where man who would you rather be like a
medium or not so good black belt or like
the best brown belt like who would you
vote as far as that kind of thinking
goes innocently man I'd rather be the
good brown belt really you know cuz
you're rolling a row with your buddy
like everyone knows the black belt is
not that good you know you don't want to
be that guy it's free if you think if
you're thinking like that you know so
it's like you know I get it I make sense
and then of course if you can get to the
maturity level to think well when it if
it does happen I'm gonna be so happy
that it happened
the way if you can get there then it's
like okay that'll make you feel better
too and that's again if you're even
focusing on that that belt situation so
when I even thought about it and when
I'd hear all this stuff that like yeah
like these people want to like promote
you but then Jaco like doesn't you know
kind of thing then I'd be then that when
I think about it be like I think to
myself yet I'd basically have to tap Joc
around like not even wants to like the
kind like I'd have to i'd have to tap
him out a few times for him to like
consider giving that's what I just
figured you just kinda got to that place
yeah mine yeah so that was it and then
so it's in a way it's easy to get or it
made it easier for me to not even focus
on it anymore it's kind of like did you
talk about chocolate oh you know okay
then let's move on kind of thing in your
own mind you know but let's say let's
say I did tap you out though that would
throw me right back into the downward
spiral focusing on belt so that's the
kind of the back so eventually I came to
the conclusion this is probably like
leading not like the months or year
maybe leading up to it it's like chuckle
might give me a black belt when he's on
his deathbed and we're done with this
life and or he's done with this life
hopefully I don't die before him in here
we you know boom I have a black belt
and I real had that thought like
whatever you know so you went from like
okay he's holding up for a little while
- okay I gotta tap him out before he's
gonna give it to me okay so he's just
now I'm never gonna get in ever yeah and
keep in mind I'm not thinking this every
single day I'm saying when I did think
about that or when people would be like
oh you're black belt or whether those
are the thoughts that was going on you
know I this was years ago I had a
conversation with James Nielson about
this because I forget who we were
looking at promoting to black belt but I
was like yeah you know maybe in like six
months and then they were like you know
James was like bro he's good or she's
good and I was like yeah I'm like and I
I think I said like hey that person has
never even passed my guard before right
you know it might have even been about
you but I don't think it was I think it
was an earlier black belt I think it was
maybe like Craig or someone in
that group and James is like hey we're
much better than we were when we got our
black belts which is so you know I got
my black belt a long time ago right mm
right before right so that's like what
14 years ago so 14 years ago I I've had
my black belt for 14 years so how much
better I've done so much training I mean
I've done more training as a black belt
than I did without a black belt for sure
and high-level training so you can't
think oh I can't compare you because I
don't I mean but the same thing right
if I held the standard of view of like
well Echo's never tapped me out so I'm
never gave I'm giving this black belt
when he taps them up that's an unfair
standard because I'm Way better than I
was 14 years ago when I got my black
belt so that's not a fair standard so
yeah that's that's that's not a good but
it's not most apples though in that way
because like there are certain people
where it's like like Andy for example he
his skill rose so fast that away I mean
did he has he ever tapped you out before
he got his black belt I think he did I
think he got me I think he got me like
one time but I think it was like as a
purple belt and it had no influence on a
black belt okay um it just seemed like
with Andy and whether this was the case
sir I just seemed like this could be a
possibility in this type of equation
where they rise so fast and they get so
good so fast um that it's like bro like
I have no choice but to give this guy a
black pepper he's straight up he's
tapping me out and I've been a black
belt for 15 years you know it's it's
kind of like that kind of the kind of
attitude but yeah so it's not like a
apples apples to a street in their way I
guess but but it's true though yeah
you're a so I could I couldn't be like
oh well what I'm just gonna have to wait
until I hope taps me out to get his back
but cuz when is that going to happen
right could it happen today
sure it could happen today but you might
not tap me
for another two years right I mean like
that's that's the reality of the
situation you might tap me out tonight
right I make a mistake you get a good
move it can happen but it might take a
long time I mean there's people that
have never tapped me out and you know it
just happens he's like this doesn't mean
that they're not worthy of you know
exactly doesn't matter doesn't mean that
so it's one of those things where I had
to kind of recognize that you know we're
better now than we were then but to
counter that argument everyone's better
now than we were then so probably a good
purple belt right now would be able to
beat me as a black belt 14 years ago
right a modern purple though yeah
a modern perf like do you watch the
worlds did you I mean you watch the kids
at the worlds the the the purple belts
out the worlds are savages yes right
when you compare them especially to a a
black belt from 14 years ago 14 years
ago is a long time ago the game has
evolved a lot but so you were not
expecting at all when we were able to do
that you know I know so what I did was I
read it ran it because you weren't ready
and I was like okay you know that goes
that goes good to go you should be
having as black but I will watch you
roll that's another thing I were to
evaluate is how you roll with other
people not just with me cuz that's not
fair either right because how does your
game match up with me nothing about the
best way you know and I would watch you
roll with someone that's good with me
and I'm like you're doing better against
that person so I you know it's the same
thing with everyone like you've watched
them rolling you gotta you know you
should you're killing this person or
you're killing that person even though
you're not killing me that person's
given me a hard time so therefore it's
just your game doesn't match well with
with me which doesn't mean that you're
not ready it just means it's a bad
matchup yeah that's yeah it's not linear
like that for sure so yeah so it was
awesome to have that go down I know it
was a long haul when
to making stuff easy no sir around looks
okay so what's the future hold for Echo
Charles at this time up man for what for
jujitsu
the same I think I feel like it's like
so did it and thinking back on it and I
kind of had these feelings even kind of
coming up for 14 years where white belt
you just like I taught your life toddler
kindergarten you know kind of you know
and then you get through blue belt and
purple belt you're like you know
elementary intermediate high high school
and then brown belt is kind of like
college you know you sort of feel like
you're an adult and you're in there you
can do some good things you know have an
impact on the world in college talk
about in college um and then but you
just learn it's you should be learning
in there and then then you get black
belt it's like you graduated from
college now you got to go function in
the real world now you know so it's like
man in a way people say oh you just who
just begins at black belt and yeah in
that way it totally does and that's not
to mention all the little superficial
things that kind of come good and bad by
the way they come with it like when you
when you're a black belt okay so if
you're not a black belt and you tap out
a black belt that's a that's a good
feeling you know it's like one of those
little things in your mind that you're
like I tapped out a black belt before
you know kind of thing so now you have
that kind of target on your back if you
want to put it that way
you're gonna give other people that good
feeling yes you're a target for that so
people you can tell people's attitude
when they roll with you is little bit
different
oh well it might be an illusion but I
feel like it's different like physically
and then um that's not to mention like
you know the stuff that maybe the other
black belts might have like whose black
belt like me I don't know if it's them
expecting me to like I'm a black belt
now so I'm gonna put it on you or what
but every once in LA feel a little
something like oh you you seem like this
role means a little bit more now than it
does before it's like I get that feeling
sometimes I'm not all the time but
there's that but yeah like how we're
talking yesterday or whatever it's like
it doesn't really change anything you
know like just goes my belt half happens
to be a different color it's like you're
as good as
you are you know it doesn't make your
digital game it does not write the
future yet no I just keep training you
know I guess I mean there's in most ways
I feel like the pressure is sort of off
and more so than it's off it's more like
I don't I'm not susceptible to that that
wacky way of thinking like oh you
promote it oh did I did did I perform
well so Dean and Jocko saw you know the
pressure that I feel which is a good
pressure is like you when you're a black
belt man you got to maintain yeah yeah
you gotta maintain you gotta train you
got to maintain you don't wanna be
rolling you don't want to put a black
belt on and not represent not have the
skills manhunt you present so and look
it doesn't you're gonna win every time
like there's people that are training
more than you and you're doing stuff and
it's like yeah but you should have black
belt level skills yeah period in the
story yeah period end of story
and I think that that makes it in I
guess it depends on what you mean but I
I think that makes it easier for you
like how you say it's good pressure it's
like it it's not even price it's more of
like a it's like it's like a cool little
push you know like it's almost like I'm
like you know these celebrities or
whatever like an actor or something
right when he has to play Wolverine so
he has to work out you know it's like
right you got to be Wolverine on this
movie so work out okay of course you
know kind of thing rather than let's say
you didn't have the movie but you still
got to work out it's you know it's kind
of different so yeah like training more
in maintaining kind of the you know the
standard or whatever and I feel like
it's like easier Akbar yes Akbar yeah
for those either don't know if Bart uses
awesome fighter and crazy Jiu Jitsu he
was in he was you know he fought in the
UFC never really you know he never
performed to the level of his capability
unfortunately you know he you know he's
just incredibly skilled and he just
didn't put it together right
you know circumstances things happened
you know his opponents did things that
were good you know it's like that's the
way it is but he did pretty good in the
800 had some pita
oh yeah he's but anyways
he's awesome to train with but like I
always had a rule with him and we had a
rule with each other if it's you want if
you want to train we're gonna train like
so there's no because both of us kind of
know it's gonna be a it's gonna be a
crushing roll it's gonna be it's gonna
be gnarly and you know what we had
though we had the rule at first it was
an unwritten rule and then one day I
just said I was like hey no matter what
do you want a wall we're rolling it and
he's like hey if you wanna roll we're
rolling yeah
so he but he just he said came started
training again yeah there was a savage
yeah freaking hard work when he rolls he
rolls
oh yeah he's going for it you know he's
gonna bring it you know yeah he's gonna
bring it and videos you're gonna start
making some more videos yeah videos hard
because like especially now that videos
are I don't even know if I told you this
fully but like videos are so common now
yeah that like back when I made the
victory videos it was like yeah you
already learned ahead of your time wait
that's the thing and looking at them now
you're like oh ho that's part kind of
cheesy kind of funny not fun they're
like cool but it's like you know you
should post those on the darker podcast
Channel so people can watch them yeah
okay um but watching those videos now
like those videos would not make a mark
right now no no no just say another one
because they're good or not good at
nothing like I'm just saying like videos
are they're just so much everywhere so
it starts to become like a wash of just
many many millions of videos so granted
sure like there's you and you know are
all our people they they watch our
videos regardless of what they are
whatever I mean not regardless but um
like we do have an advantage as far as
eyeballs as far as videos or people
caring about the videos okay to me the
the ocean of videos like it's hard to
get people to care about videos so you
kind of got to be selective I think so
if I put like a bunch of videos out I
don't want people to are people to be
like oh cool and sort of get bored with
them you know so it's like you want to
leave a mark yeah so I mean it caused me
to be a little bit apprehensive with
like just flooding you know
the place Vidya the cool thing is
there's people making all kinds of
videos anyways with us in them yeah so
yeah they're out there yeah but yeah you
know no no it's weird it's right but
keep in mind too though I'm like the
opposite of you in this way where I'm
like like way more like hesitant like
I'm also worried about that you know
probably to the point where I shouldn't
be worried about that quite yet
well yeah we'll make some videos up at
that cool you know
DEFCON awesome for anything else man
thank you for giving us your history
Jimin actually seems like a good place
to wrap it up people been asking for a
while for some more echo Charles they
got it they can't kind of get it on the
grounded podcast to the other podcast
that we have yeah yeah a little bit it's
some yeah you uh yeah it's a little bit
more representing in I don't know
sometimes in the support part it's all
of this podcast yeah yeah it's like a
representative of kind of back like you
know okay if we're done training or
something right and well I don't know me
or Greg or somebody brings some
something up like some subjects and
topics a question for you or each other
whatever and you start talking about it
and then I start talking about it and
you're talking trash to me like you're
you know like all just that whole thing
or whatever um it's a little more casual
Kosan yeah the grounded kind is more
skewed like in that regard well check
well speaking of conversations I'm gonna
be having some live conversations with
people now you're gonna come to some of
the shows I'm not sure why which ones
but we're even though as people have
pointed out I told everyone that you
know Ashla in front is not a rock band
we're not going on tour yeah well I am
going it's not actual on front just me
and I am going to multiple cities so I
guess that does make it a tour live gigs
January 6th in DC January 11th in Austin
which was the first one that sold out
January 16th in New York January 20th
and LA
January 27th in Seattle in January 28th
in SF so at those gigs if you're
wondering what I am going to do I am
going to talk I'm gonna dive into some
subjects I am going to do some QA from
the crowd live which is enjoyable for me
and I'm just going to go deep on some
subjects the only I've only done one
live event from that that would be
closest and that was the live podcast
that we did in New York City number 160
and this isn't gonna be a podcast and
that I'm not gonna well we might turn
these into podcasts we might take a
compilation of some of the questions or
take a compilation of some of the things
that I cover and make them into a
podcast but not all of it will be in a
podcast and I don't the reason that I
didn't want to do a podcast is I don't
want to put any framework around this I
want to be able to really just go and
get after it
with no no framework and just be able to
get after it hard and that I know let's
I have no real of the way of saying it
that's what I want to do is I want to go
hard on these on these events and with
no framework and and make it happen so
that's what I'm doing go to Chaco
live.com if you want to come to those
and echo firt sorry so you've been
talking today about kind of some of the
things that you've done to improve your
life get yourself will say on a tighter
a tighter sort of span of the path sure
and there's good ways to do this you
know life and not to mention you can do
that while you're supporting this
podcast yeah if you want to it's true
you can support yourself for sure we're
highly recommended yes you can support
the podcast too if you want to
up to you because this podcast doesn't
start off with 12 minutes of
advertisements and will not beholden to
our sponsors because that's because
we're not we don't we don't actually
have sponsors and you can press stop
right now could you know what we're
gonna talk about staying on the path
representing while we're on the path
tips in I don't see tricks cuz no trick
no trick
we'll see guidelines to maybe help you
along the way
mm-hm help everyone along the way help
you your husband or wife kids everything
the whole gig I like it
first thing you do Jiu Jitsu talked
about it a little bit today a little bit
a life-changing activity by the way you
ever think about who you'd be without if
you didn't did you just I would I've
told you this I've told everyone this
because I've been at on this podcast and
I have the thread that connected things
for me was jiu-jitsu now what's
interesting is you did you Jitsu you
didn't have the other pieces did you had
you didn't have the other pieces but you
just you allowed once you saw the other
pieces is like oh if there's the thread
there's how these things connect for me
I had the other pieces no jiu-jitsu no
connection gotcha Jitsu got connection
you were the opposite had jiu-jitsu no
other pieces oh cool
God got the other pieces now as yeah
interesting so so we want to do
jiu-jitsu we do without jiu-jitsu jaco
ceases to exist ceases to exist do you
know that in a seal platoon there's a
pecking order that makes sense that
pecking order straight up it's based on
like hey who's gonna win in a fight
that's the way it it makes sense this
way yes and and you know what that is
not only in SEO platoon there's just
like that underlying current so what's
nice is if you know jiu-jitsu you're
gonna move up in that pecking order a
little bit that is how you put that into
words that way I agree with that that's
true and it applies to a lot of
situations that in a way I almost don't
even want to Sam but do we kind of
already know you know that it that
pecking order structure hierarchy or
whatever that let's just say it exists
all right and yes you did to helps you
in that I'm not saying that's the main
benefit what's cool about a seal platoon
the reason I can start by saying a seal
platoon is because in a super tune that
pecking order is not always theoretical
so there's times you get some van fights
right that's gonna happen there's gonna
be a van brawl and and all of a sudden
the pecking order is revealed yeah and
so you feel it but then when you get to
see it you go yeah I was right there's a
little those little pecking order here
yeah it has nothing to do with your rank
yeah here's what it is and so when you
see it when you see it in the in the
under current and the under beneath the
surface when you kind of think it's
there and a seal platoon and then it
gets revealed you're like oh yeah it was
there then you see it everywhere and you
go oh yeah it's over there - oh yeah
it's over there - you can just see it
and it's a real thing so why not elevate
yourself
Elleni yourself yeah on that little
hierarchy a little bit with some jujitsu
doesn't mean you're running around
choking people out nope but you can you
can if you so when you get to you need
to get an origin this is the thing
people are gonna hear that right there
they can replay that and say you know
someone's gonna go oh yeah I see what
this is this is like a macho bully thing
right it's like hey I'm sorry to break
the news to you this is a reality yeah
this is a reality yeah and that's a good
point we're like yeah I think that when
you think about it yeah I think that
someone could come to could get almost
like triggered I'm not gonna use the
word triggered but someone could just
get moved into thinking that but yeah
whether that's the case or not it's like
you can say that about anything you know
like the thing I'm not sitting here
saying hey I'm not sitting here saying
oh well this is
one it should be like or this is what
this is uh this is how things have
turned out or this is good or this is
bad I'm not saying any of those things
I'm just telling you what it is yeah
factually actress is what it is well
factually that applies to everything in
life like okay you know you hey check
this out just by the way you can be the
best fighter in a seal platoon and
everyone can hate you
well I mean a good operator doesn't
anything well I'm just saying it's there
and it's it's one of the many little
it's one of the many things that are
being judged
yes one of them it's one of the many
things that are being judged it's one of
the many games that are being played
it's one of the many little hierarchies
that are existing and so why not elevate
yourself in that game that's my question
the reason that the reason to not
elevate there are no good reasons to not
elevate because when you elevate
yourself in that game it actually will
elevate you in other games in your life
so train jiu-jitsu people yeah this
isn't by the way this isn't 1995 when I
started you Jitsu and you had you were
lucky if there was a disc or somewhere
around you this is America in 2020 and
there are jujitsu schools everywhere or
you can go online and you can go to
youtube for free and watched YouTube get
some of your friends to rolling on the
carpet and you can learn some jiu-jitsu
learn some you get to get yourself an
orange inky you know cuz you're gonna
need 140 kids you know yeah it was funny
because you know I don't train ghee as
much right so it's been a while when
we're involved in the promotion of Andy
Berke well to get his first first degree
degree on his black on the black belt
the black though yes you know I put back
on the rift I came out with my rift on
and I said when you put it on it's not a
completely different scenario that's
just going on so good I kind of felt and
I'm I'm admitting this to you and
whoever's listening because we're real
close like that and I trust you guys a
lot but I'm gonna admit this I felt a
little bit
elevated ly kind of better in a small
way because of that yeah you you know
you have to do Pete the the folks that
made this key you have to give like
legitimately say yes you elevated the
game this is a game changer this is not
normal yeah this isn't like this isn't
like hey we took a sports car and we put
racing stripes on it
this isn't like hey we took a sports car
and we put rims on it this is you're
driving a sports car
I'm flying by you in a raptor and an
f-22 Raptor yeah so yeah very very good
so yeah I get it origen mancom that's
where you get them so you get a
multitude of options oh by the way
including rash guards when you do noogie
which i think is important they're both
important right now preferring noogie
well then again I don't know I'm like I
kind of want you know I saw you
wait did you sweep Greg train yes yes
because great trains hard to sweep yes
you got that wrestling background yeah
but you have tied up that hand a little
bit weak ovary when they get yes we know
that you go in phases right noogie
but yeah so if you do know geek boom
rash guards as well all available or
domain.com they also have jeans
speaking of elevating the game yes sir
I'm gonna tell you right now get some
origin genes and I will say this the
lightweight jeans which are called Delta
68 mmm-hmm those are possibly the best
leg coverings that exist and I have to
call a cover because you can include all
kinds of things in right we could be
your kilt that covers your legs right we
could be a wet suit bottom that could
cover your legs you know we could be
over there's all kinds of things that
can cover your legs so I'm I'm putting
all leg covering all leg covering in the
world
just saying Delta 68 origin jeans are
the best things you can cover your legs
with the world has ever known
okay this bolt I know because
technically not to go too deep into it
but whatever so technically you know
when you talk about wet suit bottoms mm
kilt all these other things those are
like circumstantial like you know
there's for certain scenarios right like
specially when you talk about what suits
or space or something like this so
you're saying at the end of the day net
net as they say oh I don't really like
the expression net but whatever
net net meaning under the circumstances
that you wear a wet suit bottom versus
jeans under the circumstances you'd ever
wear jeans were the light jeans best 100
percent across the board what I just
said is what I meant overall in the
world which this is 2020 and I'm saying
of everything that's been invented to
put on your legs mmm this is the best
thing that's been invented Delta 68 now
the the heavyweight jeans awesome - and
they're cut running that close second
but my legs don't get cold so I don't
need that little extra plus I live in
Southern California yeah but that's true
Co but Delta 68 that's the one
yeah but heavyweight the the Rick
they're not heavyweight they're just
normal jeans they're normal jeans and
they're awesome too
but they're in second place yeah man so
I thought you know for Pete they're in
first place what the heavy weights yeah
well he's up in Maine so yeah he's up in
Maine he gets that a little bit Hughes
in Southern California might have a
different opinion yeah I'm gonna I'll be
it doesn't matter to me because my legs
don't get cold so it's not a factor so
they're you know something like so by
the way if you knew that away all the
stuffs made in America did I mention
that though it's like the little tiniest
little tagline made in America actually
the huge factor huge yeah all the
building materials are made in America
that's how made in America this mean in
America stuff is oh wait we're gonna
bring stuff in from other countries no
no no we're gonna grow it here American
hands yeah breakdance American icon
everything made in America so yeah also
yeah joggers you know sweat stuff good
stuff supplements though yes
like I said import
in supplements joint supplements you can
have all the creatine a mega mass
whatever in the world if your joints
aren't working you might as what you
just spinning your wheels you're not
even spinning your wheels your wheels
are locked and wheels are locked up like
your elbow or like your shoulder ya know
don't allow that to happen
get all that joint warfare krill oil get
yourself some discipline go multiple
choices you got up you got a pill right
a little go pill you need that little
you're going into a meeting you're
getting ready to roll to JIT whatever
you're doing something that needs a
little extra cognitive boost boom take
one of those haters you get the going a
can't yeah why because it's 2:40 4:00 in
the afternoon
you're been up early it was leg day you
were up late you're feeling a little bit
of a drag cool and crack that open and
you're on fire ready to destroy the
world also milk protein additional
protein in the form of a lovely dessert
yeah good there's some chocolate
chocolate peanut butter I think that
heavily in the rotation heavily in the
rotation somebody told me to mix
strawberry and peanut butter have you
done that was that you that told me to
do that I have not done any butter but
pretty butter and jelly sandwich yeah
I'm gonna try it at some point no oh I
think what I did was I had chocolate
with yeah I don't know I remember if I
did those a long time ago and my mind's
not even on that right now
I remember mixing a banana with the
strawberry and I was something that's
gonna be good yeah either way it's all
good and you know some people they
prefer just the vanilla my middle
daughter is in college right now and she
she sends me little videos or pictures
sure
and she's and what why you know she
sends me one that says literally a
strawberry milkshake
yeah so anyways that's my daughter
yeah and that's and she's she's in
college studying nutrition so what she's
studying yeah yeah stem so the world
makes sense in weight stem yeah yeah
that's right take science you know that
thing
yes yam it cools in there yes I mean
that nutrition so she's giving me
feedback it's good and and you know it
feedback she gives me she's like
surprised that the ingredients are good
okay so good you really do and I'm like
all telling ya yeah as if I didn't make
it yeah and she's surprised that's what
your kids kids think you're an idiot I'm
like well thank you darling so very nice
of you
although jock white tea if you like
deadlifting or if you don't like
deadlifting you probably don't like
deadlift because you get can deadlift
that much yeah
as soon as you can deadlift eight
thousand pounds you like it more oh yeah
big time take it from me but yeah
certified organic too by the way so yeah
get that all that or Jemaine calm also
chocolate at the store
it's called Yakko story you can get jock
white tea at this store too by the way
but or should I say and their shirts if
you want to represent this plain equals
freedom good good is a dead one that one
is late like down downs one that won't
ever go away you need that concept good
mmm for the rest of your life some
people have gotten tattoos that just say
good and I understand 100% and just
understand I dig it
there's a good news it was a good we
also have hats truckers hats beaneasy
knees hoodies good stuff there yeah make
it so yeah if you want to represent
while you're on the path Jocko store.com
also subscribe if you haven't already
wants DJ and iTunes Google Play you know
is it important to subscribe hey you
know what um you be the judge whatever
you like but I think it's conducive to
remaining on the path I think so just
subscribe don't click subscribe boom
again that's a good question is it a
good idea to is it important to
subscribe subscribe to the podcast so
you
it's out don't forget that we also have
the grounded podcast and we also have
the warrior kid podcast which there's
four new episodes
right before Christmas we're uploaded so
check out the warrior kid podcast and
you can also get some warrior kids soap
from me young Aiden who's making soap on
his farm so that you can stay clean very
nice hmm
actually that's good soap to which I
haven't mentioned in a while it's not
this decorative table piece
no it's functional it's actual for real
soap that you use you know it's funny I
watched my boy with it he's pretty good
branding from Haiti right we're not mad
at like really like he wraps them in
these little burlap thing oh yeah oh
yeah this came from a farm this a kid
made this a kid that's super squared
away yeah
looks kind of rough you know like well
that's the reason I said branding in a
funny way is cuz people talk about hey
we need to work on our branding yeah you
know what his branding is doing his job
yeah making the stuff that works and
functionally is able but he's able to
produce you know that's what it is and
he gets it to you boom one shows up boom
good job
eight in keep it up mmm yes it is true
yeah I use that that's heavy in the
rotation to both kinds Jocko and trooper
so what's the new the one that is coming
out or the antibacterial yeah there's
one that's coming out antibacterial
antimicrobial microbe real microbial
yeah micro feel it's anti that yeah and
and it's got a really good name they say
the name you did uh I'm trying to Blaine
keep me with it again killer soap you
know way killer that's it killer so kill
yourself right yeah book it yes I'm
killing microbes yeah we're the healing
fungus yep good at least making a hard
environment for them to survive it yeah
yeah
difficult cuz killing it is would take
like chemicals that I'm not sure young
Aiden could put into a soap yeah yeah
we're not done with that we're putting
this on our skin so yes make this also
YouTube we do have a YouTube channel
official it's good one video version
some excerpts on their varying lengths
we'll just leave it at that
and you know some enhanced excerpts
every once in a while - it's good it's
cool YouTube before them you know if
that's how you listen to the podcast or
should I say watch it we do have a
YouTube channel so yeah I would say
subscribed now but then YouTube actually
yeah you want to subscribe that seems
like a good place to subscribe because
then you have it in here what it does
then he then YouTube's kind of telling
you a when a new podcast comes out or a
new video comes out and B it kind of
involves that whole algorithm so it's
showing you like oh this video here
you'll like this one right what you seem
smart yeah because if you like the
podcast maybe like some other thing that
they figured out that other people are
listening to right yeah not to mention
ease of access as well if you're like
hey let me you know if you want to
revisit one or someone told you about
like a video excerpt it's like easy you
can kind of click on your little
subscriptions or whatever rather than
going through YouTube's search let me
see is that the one is that the one you
know I'm saying something yeah just
subscribe to youtube but if you really
want to be in the game you get alerted a
there's that Bell thing you can click on
click on the little Bell get alerted
every time boom you really want to be
alerted do that man
psychological warfare another another
opportunity to stay on the path because
when you sometimes you go to the path a
little bit you're gonna think about
slipping off the path you're gonna think
that those donuts are looking good no
press play on your mp3 phone player
which whichever and listen to me telling
you why you do not want that donut why
you want to go to the gym why you want
to get up in the morning why you want to
complete that product just a bunch of
things that you can let slide don't let
it happen
get psychological warfare for yourself
if you need a visual representation
check out flipside canvas dot-com for
art there you go
to hang on your wall run by my brother
Dakota Meyer also have some books
leadership strategy and
tactics it's coming out January 14th so
if you haven't ordered it you best order
it now otherwise you're going to be
stained for life stick stigma
stigmatized with a second dish and I'll
meet you and I'll thank you but deep
inside we'll both know not just me if it
was just me don't worry about it right
but you're gonna feel it too you're
gonna know that you got yourself that
second addition you're gonna know that
when you should have ordered you
hesitated at the moment of truth don't
do it way the warrior kid series there's
three of them one two and three just
awesome feedback from around the world
on those books so if you know a kid
you're around kids you have kids get
your kids get those kids get these kids
get all kids this book don't need it to
your library I wish I had this case I
wish I could give this book to every kid
in the world right now I need your help
make it happen this is this this book is
just look it's not even mine it's not
even my book it's just everything I've
learned from people throughout my whole
life captured into this book so kids
need it
miking the Dragons for the littler kids
that are better let's face it when
you're a kid you're scared
the world is an imposing place you need
to learn how to overcome those fears
Mikey and the Dragons will teach you how
teach your kids how to do that but
basically teach you how to do it to pay
attention the field manual discipline
was for you freedom feel me I know it's
a new year this is the book you want to
get someone for the new year January
they already fell off their new with
their new year's resolutions get them
the Field Manual discipline equals
freedom Field Manual get some audio for
yourself on iTunes Amazon music google
play all their mp3 platforms get it
there
and then of course extreme ownership and
the dichotomy of leadership that I wrote
with my brother
Lafe babban where you will learn the
fundamental principles of leadership and
then we also have a shell on front which
is our leadership consulting company
where we solve problems through
leadership if you want me or someone
from the echelon front team to come and
talk to your company to come and work
with your company go to echelon front
comm we also have EF online which is
look leadership is a really complex
there's thing and yet it's simple so how
do you get information to people look
some people can read that I get it some
people can grasp information from
reading but not everyone does sure you
get everyone on your team get them
extreme ownership get them the
leadership strategy and tactics get them
the dichotomy leadership that's awesome
some people aren't going to absorb it
that way and even if they do absorb that
way they need repetition they need to
see it again from a different angle they
need to actually practice it go to EF
online.com when you get repetition you
get to see different angles and you get
to practice leadership situations
Interactive EF online.com if you want to
come to a leadership event with us go to
extreme ownership comm this is a
leadership event we do we are doing it
in 2020 we're doing it in Orlando we're
doing it in Dallas and we're doing it in
Phoenix so if you want to come keep
checking extremely ship comm for details
there all of these events have sold out
and these are gonna sell out too so get
in on it early and last we have EF
overwatch and EF Legion where we are
taking we are taking leaders from every
level of the military and placing them
in to civilian companies so that they
can use those leadership skills that
they have they can they can learn the
industry specifics when they show up
that's no factor military people are
trainable but
these are folks that understand the
principles of extreme ownership and the
dichotomy leadership in the laws of
combat and they will help you and your
company go to e F overwatch calm or EF
Legion calm and then if you still want
to hear more from echo Charles and me
well we are available on the interwebs
on Twitter on Instagram and on the echo
is adequate Charles and I am at
chocolate Lincoln once again thank you
to echo Charles for pressing record but
more important thank you for being
humble and for having my back and
supporting this podcast you do
everything for the podcast except for
the little part that I do so everything
on the back side is awesome and I
appreciate you covering all that so I
can do my little piece up front and on
top of that the podcast would not be
possible without everyone that is
listening supporting it so everyone
that's listening and spreading the words
spreading the word about the podcast and
telling your friends to listen and
getting a deaf core t-shirt or an Origin
key or a pair of Delta 68 jeans it's all
of you that make this podcast possible
so thank you for your support and of
course this podcast is also possibly
because of the sacred freedom that we
enjoy which is provided by the soldiers
sailors airmen and marine who sacrifice
their freedom and sometimes their lives
for our freedom in our lives so thanks
to all of you and to our police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers and Border Patrol
and Secret Service and all first
responders
we are also here and able to do this
podcast because of what you do so thanks
to all of you for your service and to
everyone else out there just remember
that it is a hard path in jujitsu and in
life and there are ups and downs and you
will get injured and you will get beat
down and you will get tested and those
hard days will go on and on and on but
if you impose discipline in your life if
you play the long game and think
strategic and if you stay on the path
and keep moving forward
you will end up achieving what you want
to achieve that will happen so put on
that ghee step on to the maths of
justice in jiu-jitsu and in life and
keep getting after it and until next
time this is echo Charles and Jocko